Guten Morgen Tim.
Kann ich sagen hochdosiertes Vitamin D Johanniskraut Tageslichtlampe Sport ja und hat diesen riesigen Boxsack an dem ich mich den ganzen Tag aus lasse.
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 277 vom 22 November 2018 eure persönliche lebensberatungs Änderungen zum Management Kosten Wut.
Bei uns übrigens jetzt hier in unserem infowars Shop geht's jetzt wieder lustige Globulis bestellt sie jetzt weil im Trinkwasser ist ja von der Regierung.
LSD.
LSD und mit unseren Globuli Kügelchen könnt ihr das LSD rausfiltern.
Um dann quasi potenziert Eintrittspforten in die Netzpolitik und ich sage euch es wird ein Horror.
Finger weg von dem Zeug Netzpolitik auf LSD.
Das macht richtig Farben.
Ja
Er könnte erst mal sehen was wir richtiges Schwarz.
Ja also um unsere persönliche Verzweiflung im Grenzen zu halten holen wir uns dann immer Gäste rein die Reisenden immer alles raus ne Thomas.
Hallo Tim Hallo Lina.
Hallo Tor.
Genau wir begrüßen Thomas Thomas im Rudel nicht Lohninger wenngleich auch Witze indischen Migrationshintergrund.
Das hatten wir ja hier vor einigen Sendungen auch schonmal dargelegt von daher bist Du ja ein Wiedergänger trotzdem.
Sollte nicht unerwähnt bleiben auch du arbeitest für net Fritig,
Ork und schreibst dort fleißig wir hatten uns vor
nach zehn elf Monaten in der UNESCO t244 unterhalten nachdem wir diese schöne Pressereise zu EU-Kommission gemacht haben.
Das ist schon so lange her.
Das war im Februar ja.
Ein 11 Monate.
Wenn ich mich jetzt nicht komplett mit Zähnen nee 99.
Es ist viel zu.
Ja viel zu früh genau Holger bleich war ja auch noch mit in der Sendung das war ganz unterhaltsam,
da kam dann ja auch schon raus dass du abgesehen davon dass natürlich verschiedenste Themen behandelst auch so ein bisschen so ein Steckenpferd hast mit Infrastruktur.
Also ich achte darauf mir die positiven Themen der deutschen Netzpolitik rausgekramt und ganz wichtig für meine Psyche ausgehoben.
Ja das hast du bisher noch stabil in der Hinsicht.
Die ist doch wie kann man so nennen ja das ist eine relativ wert.
Naja ist wenn man sich die letzten Jahre ansieht gibt es einen eindeutigen stabilen Trend dass alles so bleibt wie es ist.
Na das ist doch schon mal was geht als konservativer die Sache.
Ich muss allerdings sagen ich wollte ein paar Wochen im Urlaub unter das hat meinem geistigen Gemütszustand durchaus geholfen.
War schön da und warm und alles.
Das war ganz toll ja ja ich habe mal davon Abstand gehalten regulierungs papers zu lesen das hebe ich mir für die Arbeitszeit auf.
Und jetzt ist wieder soweit.
Und wir wollen heute mal einen Schwerpunkt Aufsetzen auf deine Themen aber uns trotzdem ein wenig an der Nachrichtenlage.
Und die Nachrichtenlage sagt uns das ein Gerichtsurteil ausging vom wo werden eigentlich gerichtet.
Verwaltungsgericht Köln.
Das Verwaltungsgericht Köln hat sich geäußert zum Thema stream.on dem Spezialtarif den die Deutsche Telekom von mir.
Nachmittagsjob 20 Monate oder sowas.
Ja der Öffentlichkeit präsentiert hat wo sie gesagt haben hier,
hast du Mobilfunk und wenn du halt in Deutschland unterwegs bist dann packen wir dir hier YouTube und andere große player
einfach mal kostenlos mit rein in den Kanal sprich das rechnet sich gegen die also rechnet sich nicht gegen die sehr knapp gehaltenen
Bandbreitenbegrenzung zum
Ausweise Datenvolumen schwimmen datenvolumenbegrenzung auch Bandbreiten sind betroffen denn wenn irgendein Unternehmen halten nicht in diesem Paket mit eingeschnürt ist na dann wird er halt auch mal ein wenig.
Leider umgekehrt.
Gedrosselt was was ist umgekehrt.
Gedrosselt wird wenn du in dem Paket drin bist in dem niedrigeren Tarif.
Dann komm mal gut an aber gut dass ich hier bin ja und nein so ganz unrecht hat seitdem nicht was tatsächlich.
Moment ich weiß ich bin Österreicher versucht höflich zu sein
was tatsächlich gedrosselt wurde waren 1
was man vielleicht auch noch dazu sagen musste gesprochenen Wort kommt das nicht so ganz rüber und Tim hat gesagt kostenlos da gehört natürlich Anführungsstriche dazu also kostenlos ist natürlich nur scheinbar das ganze bezahlen wieder durch
habe Datenvolumen hohe Tarife spezielle Zusatzpakete der nur noch erworben werden müssen was,
zurückzufordern Bundesnetzagentur und jetzt eben auch dem Verwaltungsgericht Köln aufgestoßen ist wann zwei Dinge,
nämlich die Telekom Deutschland hat sich im Zuge dieses zero-rating,
wie man dazu entschlossen ganz klar gegen europäisches Recht zu verstoßen
ein zwar indem Sie dieses Angebot zur nur im Inland oder in Deutschland verfügbar gemacht haben.
Hast mich du kommst dann auf diese ganzen vielen tollen Dienste scheinbar kostenlos zugreifen
aber eben nicht im EU-Ausland zu wer das ist mal ein ganz klarer Verstoß gegen die Rom mit allerlei Cathomen fahrregelung und die zweite Sache dass es irgendwas mit der Drossel,
wenn du in bestimmten Paketen unterwegs warst und dir dann Videos anschauen wolltest wurden die daneben herunter gedrosselt auf eine SD von Qualität die einfach,
mach das licht aus sieht aber vor allem natürlich rechtswidrig.
USD klingt jetzt so so negativ DVD-Qualität 90er Jahre das ist so 90er jahre Datenträger so eine DVD 4 Gigabyte gehen auf eine DVD.
Bist du so ich habe gerade gesagt ganz ganz gut dass auch keine keine Blöcke oder sowas wirklich ganz toll ausgesehen.
Und das ist aber wie war das da diese Drosselung findet statt in denen nicht L oder XL Tarifen glaube ich ne und da wird dann.
Die teuersten Tarif wurde tatsächlich nicht gedrosselt aber ja in einer anderen Leben.
Und das findet die findet statt bei den.
Streamon Partner oder generell das war was passiert generell das war nämlich etwas was auch immer unklar war ne deshalb heißt das ich kann mit einem Telekom,
Tarif überhaupt keine HD Videos unterwegs sehen oder nur dann nicht wenn ich streamon anhabe.
Also streamon das muss auf jeden Fall aktiviert haben
unterm sobald oder wirklich in diese falsche Gruppe fällst dann dann war es dass es gibt es eine Option da kann man das ein und ausschalten aber das ist jetzt nicht sonderlich kundenfreundlich,
Maus müssen sich immer dran denken aber in erster Linie was jetzt mal auf jeden Fall also eine grundsätzliche Geschichte das halt einfach unzulässigerweise in,
Datentraffic angegriffen wurden also dein Bruder hat wirklich,
legale Inhaltsstoffe im reingeschaut,
oder infiziert okay das ist mal ein Video und das wurde dann unzulässigerweise.
So jetzt hat das Gericht so nicht.
Ja dieses Urteil.
Hat zwei Aspekte des grundsätzlich ja erstmal hat das streamon ansich nicht verboten wurde also sogenannte zero-rating Angebote das sind ja vielleicht sollten wir das auch noch mal kurz erklären
am
gibt's unbestimmte partnerdienste die beim entsprechenden Netzbetreiber anklopfen und sagen hey wir wollen unseren Dienst hat einfach möglichst breitenwirksam unter die Leute bringen.
Und auf der anderen Seite können beim Kunden zwischen Pakete rum,
je nachdem wie das in ausgestaltet ist kostenlos oder in der Regel dann auch kostenpflichtig dazu bestellen und dazu gestern noch diese Dienste der wird vom monatlichen Transfervolumen ausgenommen,
man kann es auch so ein bisschen umständlich aber recht treffend bezeichnen als Monetarisierung von knappen Netzwerkressourcen.
Das heißt man muss ich dann wirklich schon,
gut überlegen nimmt man dieses Paket nimmt man es nicht auf was greift man instant eben zu im Internet und nur durch durch die Hintertür möglich testen Netzbetreibern die Datenvolumen am möglichst knapp zu halten
so wenn diese zero-rating Angebote umso attraktiver unter das soll dazu dafür,
war das der Markt erschließen einfach keinen Anreiz hat möglichst hohe Datenvolumen noch zur Verfügung zu stellen sondern die Mutter in so Käfig einzusperren und da sind sich nicht riesen Gefahr für den letzten natürlichen für das offene Internet.
Mit wem hat sich denn die Telekom da überhaupt ins Bett liegen können es aber nicht alle so mit.
Sunny Sunny mitgespielt so sehr viele große Blasen natürlich dabei
die können sich das natürlich leisten auf also dann müssen sie natürlich Vorkehrungen treffen ihren dienst kompatibel mit diesen ganzen Angebot machen aber wenn man sich das dann natürlich europaweit ansieht dann hat man
danke für die Meere 100 Netzbetreiber das ist ein riesiger Aufwand wenn man wirklich in einem europäischen Ländern im digitalen Binnenmarkt der so reibungslos funktionieren soll laut EU-Kommission
dabei sein möchte
aber auch einige große Player sind nicht dabei also zu Mehrspieler Videodienst Vimeo das ist ja fies vor der größte Youtuber Konkurrenz
dimmbares Licht einfach zu mühsam und zu aufwändig da Mitarbeiter extra darauf abzustellen um ihre Dienste oder irgendwie irgendwelche komischen,
Sonderangebote von in welchen komischen europäischen Netzbetreibern oder anzupassen das sieht auch teilnehmen kann also das schon an einen nicht zu unterschätzenden Aufwand,
auf für die Dienstanbieter selbst.
So was bedeutet jetzt dieses Urteil was.
Ja also das ist auch nicht vielleicht auch nicht so eine sonder seine juristische diesen juristischen Scherbenhaufen jetzt noch mal komplett auflösen das war jetzt noch mal,
das Verwaltungsgericht Köln hat ein Eilantrag abgewiesen.
Preis teurer wird nur mal so einer von mehreren Schritten wieder durchlaufen müssen es gibt nur noch ein Hauptverfahren und es gibt dann noch wirst du noch mal,
Japan MMM Rechtsschutzverfahren also da wird noch mein kompletter Instanzenweg durchlaufen
bevor wirklich zu 100% und rechtswirksam festgestellt wird dass es illegal was die Telekom Deutschland der macht alle,
die sich nur halbwegs mit der Materie auskennen sagen jetzt schon voraus das ist komplett rechtswidriger da muss man sich wirklich nur diese diese TSM Verordnung hör dir das ganze europaweit regels durchlesen,
also das wird auf jeden Fall kippen die Frage ist nur wann.
Zwischenzeit natürlich verkauft diese Verkauf der Netzbetreiber dieses tolle Angebot
weil sie irgendwie durchaus attraktiv erscheint wenn man sich denkt okay ich habe gesagt nur 2 GB Daten Transfervolumen möchte aber trotzdem Regel mit,
nehme ich mir das doch,
das macht das natürlich das Netzbetreiber attraktiver das macht er bestimmt der Pakete aber so Tarifen aktiver und in der Zwischenzeit verdienen diese Netzbetreibern massiv Geld genau mit diesem Mechanismus.
Das wird dann irgendwann umgekippt in ein paar Jahren und in der Zwischenzeit haben sie halt Millionengewinner damit erwirtschaftete,
am Tropf eine Internetseite gefährdet oder möglicherweise sogar ein bisschen eingeschränkt das ist natürlich kein tragfähiges.
Und das potenzielle Strafmass ist am Ende steht in keinem Verhältnis zu dem was man da ge.
So ist es ganz genauso das Strafmaß ist auf 500000 € begrenzt
sowie dass die Bundesnetzagentur derzeit durchzieht aussieht sie einen Strafrahmen von 100000 € pro Verfehlung vor dass es in dem Fall wären das dann so wie es aussieht 200000 €,
wesentliche das öffnet Tür und Tor für Missbrauch weil aber solche Unternehmer dadurch aus der Portokasse.
Sinnvoller wäre sozusagen 100.000 pro Kunde.
Beispielsweise also wirklich empfindliche Strafen die auch keinen tatsächlichen effektiven Abschreckungseffekt haben aus da lachen die natürlich.
Beantworten den kannst eigentlich wirklich egal sein sagen so ob das dauert einfach da mal zwei Jahre und danach zahlen wir ein bisschen Portokasse und dann war es.
Und das ganze.
Erinnern unter Umständen das Angebot soweit es halt weg geklagt wurde wegen wieder irgendwas anderes draufmachen das Spiel immer weiter.
Das könnte so funktionieren ganz genau wobei hat noch dich immer noch dieses Grundproblem bleibt das live rating Angebote an sich ja legal sind da unter bestimmten Bedingungen,
Yam.
Aber wie sich halt jetzt in beispielsweise zeigt es ist kaum möglich an inneren diskriminierendes Modell diskriminierungsfrei und rechtskonform Auszuge Stock.
Das war das ist gerade die Bedingungen ne du darfst im Rating machen aber nicht diskriminieren oder also wie genau sind denn die Bedingungen für das zero-rating das hat mir immer nicht so ganz ein geläuft.
Also Wassermesser Tollität an sich ist also da gibt's so unterschiedliche Definitionen,
unterschied Aspekte dieser Definition und ein zu ganz obersten ist das sogenannte ende-zu-ende Prinzip,
also das tatsächlich ein bisschen Datentraffic an sich nicht eingegriffen wird das nicht gedrosselt wird das dazu geführt bestimmte Dienste nicht
geblockt wird er solche Sachen der unterschied bei zero-rating zuna NWZ x Spezial links oder Überholspur and ist.
Dass der an sich nicht in den Garten spielen selbst angegriffen werden muss das heißt dieses ende-zu-ende Prinzip wird nicht verletzt
es handelt sich halt Moment ökonomisches Modell wurden so sanft der Anreize gelegt werden ja bitte nimm du doch dann
Stundentarif Monster bekommst du dann halt den Zugriff auf bestimmte Dienste kostenfrei mitgeliefert ein bisschen so wie das Kabelfernsehen
nimm auch so bestimmten argetra mitzubuchen kannst.
Solang du deine Marktmacht als Netzbetreiber beispielsweise nicht ausnutzt und ganz eindeutig diskriminieren vorgehst in du dem zurück z.b. sagst,
okay ich lasse jetzt nur einen bestimmten Partnerdienst der mir ganz ganz wichtiges der Mann vielleicht ganz viel Geld dafür getan hat und exklusiver Partner an diesem See Rating Angebot teilnehmen zu können und alle anderen außen vor lässt.
Aber das willst mach mir ein Beispiel dass wir mit ziemlicher Sicherheit illegal.
Und weil die Deutsche Telekom sagt jedes Unternehmen jeder Anbieter kann,
streamon anmelden kostet sogar nichts ist es sagen sie können sie argumentieren es wäre nicht diskriminierend.
So ist es wobei auch hier muss man Anführungsstriche setzen es kostet nichts ist eben eine rhetorische Behauptung es kostet natürlich verdammt viel Aufwand um Dienste diese Dienste
dann muss man dicker AGBs unter in dies zu berücksichtigen bei man muss beispielsweise wenn man nichts an seiner Technik.
Haftungsrisiko.
Ja irgendetwas über das ändert dann muss man am Monate zuvor dem Netzbetreiber Bescheid geben und,
die Bergans also im Falle der Telekom Deutschland Bad muss ich beispielsweise vor bis 50000 € Strafzahlungen sondern auch sprechen zu können und auch das ist eine enorme Rechtsunsicherheit insbesondere für kleine Betreiber,
kannst du Schalke natürlich von irgendwelchen International agierend oder hat man das wieder toll am Internet das man hat wirklich die Möglichkeit der diskriminierungsfreier
irgendwelche mehr oder weniger obskuren Inhalte zuzugreifen also beispielsweise gibt's da irgendwo ein ganz spannendes Internetradio in Südamerika oder wo auch immer und auf das sagt man halt gern zu.
Diese kleinen Anbieter deren Sicherheit nicht zu Telekom Deutschland gehen und sagen hehe okay und wir wollen jetzt bei euch bei stream on dabei sein die wissen gar nichts davon,
oder Hamax Schlitten einfach nicht da dete die Ressourcennutzung nebensächliche Porto zu anzupassen.
Alphakanal ich zusammenfassen.
Es ist zwar damals in dem Kampf ein gewisses Maß an Netzneutralität gesichert worden aber nicht in dem Maße dass man wirklich den eigentlich gewünschten Effekt erzielt hat das einfach die Pakete,
generöser werden für die Kunden dass man,
mehr Datenvolumen hat oder vielleicht auch unbegrenzte Tarif.
Ja und nein also.
Na eigentlich schon relativ aber nicht relativ ich bin sehr froh über die jetzt noch dreht sie dreckige Sau Europäischen Union hat diesen im großen Ganzen ziemlich gut insbesondere auch dann die Leitlinien auf dem berek
na das ist doch das eine Dachorganisation der europäischen Regulierungsbehörden die größte Gefahr wagt es liegt ein einfacher das ohne diese Regeln den Netzbetreiber,
in den letzten Tagen und warten können wie sagt wollen bestimmte Dienste diskriminierenden Zugriff sperren auf bestimmte Dienste,
aber dann gab es noch eine riesen Diskussion um Spezialdienste wurden eben zu bezahlt oder zu bezahlen der Überholspur für bestimmte privilegierte Dienste eingeführt werden können das wurde sehr sehr stark eingezäunt,
aber das letzte große Schlupfloch was tun verblieben ist das in dem tatsächlich diese zero-rating Angebote wo hat eine ökonomische Diskriminierung.
Aber es fragt man sich doch natürlich wenn wir doch solche warum lassen wir Gesetze an die sich relativ schon relativ versc.
Es ist schon relativ offensichtlich dass die Telekom sich hier nicht an das Gesetz hält das ist jetzt keine überraschendes Urteil würdest du sagen dass das Internet ein rechtsfreier Raum ist.
Das hatte ich würde mal gar nichts sagen dass es irgendwas mit dem Internet zu tun hat hat das ist halt einfach einen Macht von wirklich wirklich großen Unternehmen in Zusammenhang mit der Deutschen Telekom muss natürlich auch noch erwähnen dass ein signifikanter Anteil der Anteile immer noch beim deutschen Staat liegen sowohl direkt als auch indirekt
Arm Tattoos Finanzministerium Gewissen,
darf daran oder dein Interesse dran der Telekom nicht allzu sehr weh zu tun das Wirtschaftsministerium ist dran interessiert,
das Sagen Arbeitsplätze verloren gehen weil damit drohte Telekom Deutschland auch seit wann er seine sehr seltsame Verbandelung so hinter den Kulissen zwischen Playern
ah das ist auf dem Netzneutralität oder auch auf das Internet umzumünzen ich glaube das nicht so generelle Mechaniken die die auch in anderen Wirtschaftssektoren haben sogar zu beobachten.
Also um mal grob zumindest die.
Position der Deutschen Telekom hier auch zu würdigen die argumentieren glaube ich dass sie sagen wie verstarb ihr Streams einfach nur shapen.
Also shapen heißt ich erkenne quasi da ist ein kontinuierlicher Datenfluss.
Und jetzt gehe ich einfach hin und liebe Tiere den auf eine gewisse Bandbreite und ungeachtet dessen was das,
was ist ein Wassertag genau ist ich erkenne einfach nur dieser Datenfluss ist insofern kontinuierlich dass er ziemlich genau die so aussieht wie ein Stream ja und.
Heute heutzutage funktioniert Streaming grundsätzlich sodass.
Oder in der Regel mit adaptiven Bandbreiten das heißt dein Streaming-Server wenn du jetzt.
Wenn fällt euch vielleicht auch manchmal auf wenn ihr das dass ich,
ein Stream schaut Netflix oder sonstiges und gerettet auf einmal in die Situation
schlechten Empfang weiß ich nicht seit Formen der Küche ins Wohnzimmer gegangen oder so und Mobilfunknetz bricht zusammen oder so
dann wird er wird die Übertragungsqualität einfach schlechter das heißt da einigen sich der streamen the server und der Client stellen fest dass ihre Verbindung schlechter wird und passen dann passt der Server steht dann eine schlechtere Qualität zur Verfügung.
Und diese Funktion nutzt die Deutsche Telekom quasi aus um die Leute in diesem Fall des des des limitierend auf.
SD Qualität,
das quasi zu erzwingen ohne eine Umkodierung stattfinden zu lassen also ich glaube nicht dass bei der Telekom nicht bin mir sicher dass bei der Telekom nicht wenn man es ein Streaming-Anbieter hätte der nur ein hdstream bereitstellt,
dass die Deutsche Telekom hingehen würde würde sich quasi über den interconnect das HD Bild
holen bitte das umcodieren und dann an dein Handy nur noch SD Qualität liefern so verstehe ich das System nicht und da deswegen argumentieren die auch sie würden in den netzwerkstream nicht eingreifen sondern würden quasi alle Streams gleichzeitig
gleichermaßen diskriminieren würde zumindest nur deren deren Argumentation.
Zudem eu-roaming sagen sie.
In der EU-Roaming-Verordnung ist ja quasi festgelegt was ein,
Netzanbieter Inland alldem Netzanbieter Inland bezahlen muss wenn seine subscriber.
In diesem Land Roman und es ist ja nicht so als würde das kostenlos passieren also.
Wäre es nun so dass du eine Flatrate hättest Zeit von mir aus eine Flatrate langweilig ist jetzt immer für.
Der Einfachheit halber 50 € eine Flatrate gehst jetzt ins EU-Ausland und Ballast ein Terabyte durch die Leitung dann wäre es tatsächlich so dass der Netzanbieter ein Minus,
Geschäft hätte weil die ja quasi pro Gigabyte Datenvolumen im Ausland einen festen Betrag bezahlen müssen.
Deswegen sagte Deutsche Telekom können wir dieses streamon nicht im Ausland anbieten weil es uns da tatsächlich Geld kosten würde während wenn wir es im eigenen Netz anbieten.
Es zumindest nur virtuelle Kosten innerhalb unserer eigenen verrechnungs Buden,
sind nicht aber tatsächlich ein Geldbetrag den wir am anderen Ende einem anderen Netzbetreiber bezahlen müssen also nur um deren Begründung.
Zu zu würdigen.
Kann man definitiv machen aber das ist auch nicht ganz unrecht ich allerdings selbst oder nicht erfüllt das ist beides trotzdem ganz klar rechtswidrig und auch obwohl natürlich die Siege Roaming Preise im EU-Ausland,
ja dann entsprechend gedeckelt sind wobei die dann auch jetzt da fallen werden von Jahr zu Jahr so dass sich auch im Prozess der von der EU ausgehandelt wurde diese internet interconnect zur Gebühren das ändert trotzdem nichts daran dass.
Dann möglichweise eben dieses Datenvolumen nicht verbraucht würde ja.
Und erfand das hat natürlich Kunden nicht zu interessieren diese TSM vor Ordnung gehört die Zielzahl natürlich auch Kundenrechte ab unter wenn die Netzbetreiber ihre Modelle so nicht anbieten können
am dann sollen sie sagt nicht machen anstatt gegen rechts.
Vielleicht auch noch eine Sache die ich nicht arbeiten muss und das andere machen Gesichter Telekom noch mal zu würdigen sozusagen die Stellen dieses streamon Angebot als Riesenerfolg da
aber so eine Million Kunden oder so soll das haben gleichzeitig sagen sie natürlich okay wir haben jetzt leider nicht zu,
mit Kapazitäten um auf das sächliche möglichst um limitierte oder oder sehr großzügig bemessene Datenvolumina zu Verfügung zu stellen,
wenn streamon wirklich so erfolgreich ist wie die Telekom deutsche,
Hauptsatz dann haben sie offenbar so würde man meinen von außen.
Anscheinend doch genügend Netzkapazität,
haben also da werden dann bestimmte Dienste bzw bestimmte Kunden hat eine Frau von der ökonomischen Ebene bevorteilt,
und auch dass es nur sehr sehr schwer mit dem Prinzip dann.
Zumal das ja ganz interessant ist die argumentieren jede Daten Sau ist ja indem,
in diesen streamon inbegriffen also jede Daten Saudi denen ernsthaft Probleme bereitet na also Netflix ist da drin die ganzen Musik Dinger sind da drin man könnte eigentlich sagen dass.
Für den größeren Teil der.
Kundinnen und Kunden wenig Dienste übrig bleiben.
Die ernsthaft noch das Netz belasten würden im Vergleich zu dem was sie mit diesem streamon ohnehin,
den Leuten jetzt dann kostenlos geben ob du jetzt also du hast quasi den Vertrag du hast dieses streamon an jetzt kannst du ja irgendwie so viel Musik hören wie du willst du für YouTube hören wie du willst wenn du dann jetzt noch von mir aus dem bisschen.
Bitte und ein bisschen Facebook machst und das irgendwie im Zweig Kram hinkriegst dann,
ist eigentlich nur dein YouTube und Musik Traffic das was der Deutschen Telekom,
Kopfschmerzen bereitet und genau das geben sie dir kostenlos jetzt fragt man sich natürlich warum dann nicht eigentlich alles und der Hintergrund ist natürlich dass sie,
dann diese diese Diskriminierung oder nicht Diskussion die Unterschiede zwischen verschiedenen Tarifen nicht mehr hätten wenn sie jetzt einmal eine Flatrate anbieten dann.
Und zwar im Prinzip.
In dem gleichen Rahmen wo sie jetzt eine zwei von mir sind zwei oder vier Gigabyte Tarif anbieten was kostet bei der Deutschen Telekom AG bis 40 € oder sowas ne so ein M Tarif oder sowas.
Bisschen wenig Rampen.
Ja 35 € die Argumente argumentieren ja da gehen wir Dir quasi eine Flatrate weil Witze du hast ja kaum noch irgendwas womit du noch auf deine 23 g kommst.
Andererseits wenn Sie nicht bereit zu sagen ja komm dann kriegst du das bisschen Facebook und Twitter auch noch dazu wir kriegen unsere 35 € und Deutschland ist in der gigabit-gesellschaft.
Das hast du sie auch nicht zu na also diese Preis.
Diese diese Preisunterschiede wollen sich irgendwie auch schon bewahren um verschiedene Leute unterschiedlich zur Kasse zu bitten will das nur so schildern um um zu erklären dass das,
was Tieren ökonomische Situation ist ne.
Genau das ist mal so die unmittelbare kurzfristige Geschichte Mittel und langfristig ist natürlich für Netzbetreiber in Normen wichtige aus ihre Sicht seinem Fuß in der Tür zu haben da also sprich erst mal mit diesen Modellen zu experimentieren
stimmt der Regelverletzungen durchzuführen mal schauen wie wie die Regulierungsbehörden und Gerichte drauf reagieren also den Rahmen so weit wie möglich auszureizen und es steht nichts entgegen oder ihnen steht nichts entgegen in 10 Jahren zu lang
wenn man jetzt an sie Rating bei uns teilnehmen möchte dann
bitte dafür das gilt sowohl für die Diensteanbieter selbst also für die Kunden da hätten wir dann natürlich eine doppelte Einnahmequelle dann auch noch mit der zusätzlichen Möglichkeit.
Den Traffic auf ihren Netzen dann noch entsprechend auf riesige nee mehr Dienste zu leiten oder im.
Jetzt will ja die EU diese Netzneutralität regeln im nächsten Jahr also mit der neuen Kommission.
Analysieren und quasi auf dem Prüfstand stellen das ist vorher schon so verabredet worden und was kann man da erwarten was dann.
Passiert.
Naja wir werden sehen mein Gott versichert sein bis auf diese also dieser Evaluierungsprozess der Abend war bereit immo TSM Verordnung selbst verankert der soll dann im April 2019 Arbeit abgeschlossen sein zumindest in der ersten Phase
der Beigeschmack. Von daher dass die EU-Kommission eine Anwaltskanzlei nämlich Bodenbrett damit beauftragt hat
dieselbe Kanzlei
die Vertreter große Telekommunikationsunternehmen,
schlendern wir den Niederlanden beispielsweise vor gerichte
AWO die Telekom Deutschland eben auch ein rechtlich wackeliges Rating Angebot auf den Markt gebracht hat,
aber das wurde dann vom Gesetzgeber und von der Regulierungsbehörden eingeschränkt respektive verboten unsere dagegen sind innerhalb gerichtlich vorgegangen das ist exakt
die Anwaltskanzlei die auf Seiten Internist in einigen Teilen auf Seiten Telekommunikationsindustrie steht.
Die sollten möglichst neutral hahaha die wirksame Autolack zu überprüfen und evaluieren wie gut diese Regeln
tatsächlich greifen ob sie zu Diskriminierung geführt haben ob sie möglicherweise,
innovative auch das unter Anführungsstrichen zu setzen und Geschäftsmodelle verhindert haben ja und so weiter und so fort,
das ganze Spiel titanocene in enger Zusammenarbeit mit Barack die schon erwähnt habe aber das ist eben das ist so dass sie die europäische
Dachorganisation Haltern Zulagen Regisseur Regulierungsbehörden
anviz dann anschließend noch eine öffentliche Konsultationsphase geben wurden eben auch noch mal nachgeschaut oder wo sich deine Zivilgesellschaft zuzuwarten melden kann bzw muss um eben
na dann auch noch ein Mitspracherecht zu haben
unbekannter dich selbst schon nicht davon abhängen ok wann wird es tatsächlich dieser Bericht fertiggestellt werden welche was wir da drin stehen welche Schlussfolgerungen werden auf dem Tisch gelegt werden.
Und dann selbstverständlich wird auch sehr sehr viel davon abhängen wie die Parlamentswahlen auf europäischer Ebene im nächsten Jahr ausgehen werden wie das Kraft und möchte Verhältnis im EU-Parlament aussehen wird
in diesem Zusammenhang wird heutzutage noch einen eucomis EU-Kommission bestellt werden und abhängig davon,
wird dann alles gleich bleiben wird alles verschlechtert oder oder oder verbessert das wird sich dann noch weiß.
Aber das im Prinzip noch mal der vollständige typische Gesetzes Prozess wieder in der EU so abläuft das heißt die Kommission legt diese Überprüfung anmacht dann entsprechende Änderungsvorschläge die dann ins Parlament
gehen dort bewertet werden.
Das kann sein muss nicht sein es kann auch sein dass nur diese berec Leitlinien dann überarbeitet werden,
was soll ich das vorher schon erwähnt habe das sollte da gibt's außerdem sehr netter Tollität in Europa die steht auf zwei Füßen das eine ist eben mal diese tsd Telecom single market Verordnung.
Die regelt im nicht nur die Netzneutralität sondern eben auch die weitgehende Abschaffung der Roaming Gebühren,
weil aber an einigen Stellen diese EU-Verordnung ein bisschen unklar und unscharf formuliert war hat man berika sogenannte Leitlinien diese guidelines dann entwickelt,
die dann relativ ganz klar definieren okay was ist jetzt überhaupt ein spezialdienst was ist erlaubt was ist verboten was ist genauso Rating unter welchen Bedingungen ist es diskriminierend oder oder oder nutzt interaktiver seiner Marktmacht auch solche Sachen
alte Sachen sind natürlich sehr sehr wichtig
wobei sind das durch diese Leitlinien starken dieser EU-Verordnung orientieren was denn tatsächlich überarbeitet werden wird sollte es dazu kommen dass wir die noch weißen ist könnten nur und Anführungszeichen diese Leitlinien sein
kannst aber auch tatsächlich ja diese komplette Urfahraner noch mal aufgefüllt werden bis ziemlich halt dich das für eher unwahrscheinlich aumanwirt.
Und nur diese Bericht Richtlinie also wer bestimmt dann darüber ist das dann quasi nur die Bericht selbst in ihren eigenen Gremien.
Im Prinzip ja wobei sind da da ein sehr direkter torrent denn seine Kontakt zusammen zur EU Kommission besteht
Wetter gibt auch noch lenkungs Möglichkeiten
Sapa ist Mark noch nicht ganz unwichtig werden America ist das SAN darauf dass es seines umlach Organisation ist wird dann jeweils auf ein Jahr
Ehrenvorsitzender anhand der aus einer nationalen Regulierungsbehörde kommen zu Eschweiler aus Deutschland war das beispielsweise vor zwei Jahren oder einhalb Jahren
am im Moment ist das darum ging aber von der österreichischen RTR Regulierungsbehörde der ist an sich auch ziemlich ganz gut.
Dummerweise das A-Team die rechts rechtskonservativ extreme Regierung und ein Österreicher des Landes die man kommt ja die Regierung ist auch sehr Industrie freundlich
maramaus gekantet und ausgebootet die wird jetzt demnächst abgelöst,
und zwar uns damit ich das auch richtig hier zitiere ausgerechnet Durham Klaus Steinmaurer.
Ja das ist doch wieder Präsident Abteilung für internationale regulierungs Angelegenheiten der Deutschen Telekom also ehemalig
also da habe ich den doch sehr sehr viel Potenzial für extrem Industrie und Wirtschaft fahren Licher,
Regulierung einfach durch die Besetzung genau.
So von der USA lernen heißt siegen lernen ja sogar ein bisschen das Motto in Österreich na mal gucken wo das.
Wir hatten schon Nazis in der Regierung bevor.
Das sind die restlichen.
Na gut aber der ist ja dann nicht der chair also in dieser Phase dann ne.
In dieser Phase dürft ihr doch nicht bei share sein aber natürlich ja die die Vorbereitungen die laufen jetzt schon alt werden wir höchstwahrscheinlich auch noch ein bisschen.
Heißt es nicht klar wäre es wird es nicht so Turnus.
Doch das ist turnusmäßige ich weiß jetzt aber nicht wer das sein wird das nichts.
Das Wetter in Mainz Ebersheim
nachforschen weil wenn es irgendwie einen eine Vertreter eines generell der Netzneutralität vielleicht etwas offener gegenüberstehenden Landes wäre wäre vielleicht noch einiges zu holen na gut schauen wir mal,
so jetzt haben wir aber noch einen anderen Bären in der Höhle der.
Demnächst aus dem Winterschlaf erwacht.
Es steht an die nächste Runde der Auslobung verfügbare Frequenzen für den Mobilfunk.
Schön flauschig mit dem Stichwort 5g in den Medien und ja 5g ist Prinzip so die nächste Generation Mobilfunkstandard,
das ist jetzt auch nicht so on-off alles anders sollte im Prinzip für die Weiterentwicklung
von LTE aber arbeitet er dir mit komplett neuen Frequenzbändern die derzeit noch nicht in Benutzung sind und träum von einer
super Versorgung der Landschaft mit Highspeed-Internet überall in jeder Laterne steckt dann auf einmal
ein entsprechender Access Point.
Sehr kleine Zellen in urbanen Gebieten sind damit möglich und überhaupt die Sonne geht auf und alles wird gut,
nur jetzt muss natürlich und wie geregelt werden wie
dass es alles ablaufen soll und es steht auf der Agenda das im nächsten Jahr wieder so eine Auktion stattfindet wo sich dann interessierte Unternehmen.
Darum bewerben können diese Frequenzen zu erhalten unter bestimmten Auflagen.
Die Spielregeln für diese Auktion sollen noch in diesem Jahr festgelegt werden sollten die nicht so sein sollte das nicht sogar auch schon geschehen sein ursprünglich.
Eigentlich ja.
Eigentlich ja aber.
Oktober oder so.
Wie es so kam,
gab's wilde Debatte darum bitten diese Spielregeln den auszusehen hätten eigentlich standen sie schon fest,
nur dann hat Deutschland festgestellt dass ihr irgendwie gar nicht so gut dastehen,
was so den Ausbau von Internet im Allgemeinen und auch Mobilfunk im Besonderen betrifft und das vielleicht unter Umständen angemessen wäre,
da mal ein paar Änderung an,
bevor wir vielleicht auf diese Spezifika dieser neuen Vergabe kommen wenn ich mal ganz interessantes in den Status Quo mal ab zu also darzustellen ZW malau
zuschauen wie sich das dann ein zu entwickeln wenn ich es richtig sehe war so diese erste freie Auktion,
diese nach diesem Muster lief die Einführung von 3G in Deutschland na also GSM vorher das ist irgendwie alles noch so ein bisschen.
Dannkreis gelaufen.
Also 3G war die erste die auf jeden Fall öffentlich in dem Ausmaß auch,
Hand und wahrgenommen bekannter und wahrgenommen wurde und vor allem die erste die absolute wahnsinnspreise erzielt hat ne.
2G GSM Funk.
Weiß ich gar nicht genau da wird auch irgendetwas stattgefunden haben dass diese Lizenzen vergeben wurden die werden auch bezahlt worden sein aber 3G war dann wurde in meiner Wahrnehmung zum ersten Mal also auf diese versteigerungs Praxis
diskutiert in damals hatten wir ja auch wenn ich mich nicht täusche noch ein Mobilfunkmarkt.
Mit vier Anbietern der Erde vier mindestens.
Es ist im Nachhinein auch verständlich warum also historisch betrachtet verständlich warum das.
Damals war klar so das ist jetzt die Zukunft ne also gut ist immer entwickle aber mit 3G hattest du jetzt irgendwie zum erstenmal vertretbare
Übertragungsgeschwindigkeiten für Daten und das Internet kommt aus Telefon und es war klar entweder du machst damit.
Oder du verlierst den anschluss ne du hast jetzt von mir aus deine Investitionen in das GSM getätigt aber wenn du bei dem 3G nicht mitmacht dann wirst du relativ bald alle Kundinnen und Kunden verloren haben Andy 3G an.
Genau UMTS ist das ja damals noch.
Der in Deutschland ja wo das uber der die Spezifikationen ist Federation mobile networks.
Erinnere mich ja ja klar ich werde mich deshalb sucht das bei der Hans Eichel nachdem dann diese Auktion so viel Geld eingebracht hat so unerwartet viel Geld,
eingebracht hat Handtasche war ja damals der Finanzminister,
meinte dann halt dazu ja UMTS das stünde halt für unerwartete Mehreinnahmen zur Tilgung von Staatsschulden,
das sicherlich auch gewesen ist.
Thomas hätte ja noch sehr viel mehr zu sagen ich möchte nur anmerken dass es ja so ein.
Irrglaube ist dass diese Mehreinnahmen des Staates jetzt unbedingt von den Unternehmen geleistet worden wären ja.
Die haben so viel Geld für dieses ganze Geld was sie da ausgegeben haben um überhaupt auf dem,
funkbänder anfunken zu dürfen und diese 3G Station betreiben zu dürfen dafür hatten die noch keinen einzigen Sendemasten aufgestellter und dieses Geld haben die ja jetzt auch nicht abgeschrieben und gesagt.
Ärgerlich jetzt haben wir hier Milliarden ausgegeben oder Millionen sondern den wir gesagt alles klar das müssen wir uns jetzt irgendwo wieder herholen ich habe auch schon eine Idee woher.
Das müssten wir bezahlen und gleichzeitig hast du jetzt zur Folge weil weil es eben bei dann ging es mit 4G weiter das auch eine Auktion stattgefunden wer waren dann aber auch die Anbieter
entsprechend verhalten oder sind nicht mehr solche Rekordsummen bezahlt worden einfach weil die ja eh schon.
Inzwischen den Markt unter sich aufgeteilt hatten und ist ein bisschen klar war dass sie dieses 4ge nicht mehr.
Deutschlandweiter irgendwo hinstellen wollen oder werden und auch nicht mehr Sorge haben muss das nun wirklich aus dem Nichts Anbieter kommen und sagen coole Idee ich war jetzt ein 4G Netz ja weil sie,
also um ein 4G Netz zu bauen.
Brauchst du dieses die Infrastruktur an den jeweiligen Orten du musst Unmengen an diesem Türken hochziehen das ist einfach relativ unwahrscheinlich dass zum Zeitpunkt von vergehen noch ein vollständig neues Unternehmen.
Antritt und sagt in einem Land in dem die meisten Kundinnen und Kunden 24 Monate an Ihrem Mobilfunkanbieter gebunden sind
und hauptsächlich da bleiben durch automatische Vertragsverlängerung und schon Infrastruktur von 3,
Unternehmen oder vier Unternehmen gebaut wurde wann steigen wir jetzt in diesem Markt ein und versuchen dieses diesen Flächenstaat zu erschließen ne dass das heißt da wohnt Vandi.
Also schon etwas verhaltener gleichzeitig,
haben diese Unternehmen aber natürlich jetzt das Geld was sie da investiert haben auch im Prinzip als Investment und werd in ihren Büchern stehen das heißt wenn du jetzt sagen würdest auch und fünf geben,
bitte einfach so dann werden die Unternehmen unglücklich weil sie ja für ihre 3G und 4G Lizenzen so viel Geld bezahlt haben und deswegen versteigern wir jetzt auf die fünf gehen noch mal ne.
Im Prinzip muss ich jetzt einige noch dazu sagen,
auch leider elternberater 4G oder LTE Auktion da gabs auch Versorgungs Auflagen die mit dem Lizenz verknüpft waren auch relativ hoch 18-monatigen aber 98% Haushalter nicht auf Fläche,
durch meine langen Zeitraum gelegt also ist es nicht wenn man es diese Nutzungsrechte wirft im Rahmen dieser Auktion,
Aman Aman ja Zeit hat oder so rum wirklich jemanden komplettes Mobilfunknetz aus dem Boden zu stampfen
es ist tatsächlich richtig dass insbesondere bei diesen UMTS Lizenzen Anfang der Nullerjahre
fassbare Summen artizan Mobilfunkbetreiber in die Daten Staatskasse eingewandert sind
das ist natürlich selbst Zustand nicht ein wenig nachvollziehbar dann man das ist ja offen zu sein öffentlich verfügt,
was bekommt sozusagen das ist öffentliches Gut also ist schon ein bisschen demokratiepolitisch problematisch das einfach so privatwirtschaftlichen Unternehmen einfach so.
Ertränkende Faktoren der hier verlinkten werden damit man sollte auch nicht vergessen wieso ist ein bisschen die gesamt
politische Lage damals ausgesehen hat sie nämlich nicht ganz uninteressant warum es zu diesen Rundreisen gekommen ist das eine längere Entwicklung so in letzten 20-30 Jahren
Privatisierung der Liberalisierung.
Der Umstellung von Behörden auf Regulierungsbehörden solche Sachen das oder wurde gerade in den 90er Jahren der Telekommunikationsmarkt ganz ganz stark liberalisiert
entstanden im Zuge dessen so eine Goldgräberstimmung also sowohl im Festnetz Bereich als auch im Mobilfunkbereich
da war im Sonntag hatte diese 3G Auktion sodass zusammen Leuchten Signal am Himmel also das ist jetzt
die große Revolution da muss wirklich jeder dabei sein gleichzeitig wurde dann noch so ungefähr in diesem Zeitrahmen noch,
übereck Monopolist Deutsche Telekom,
teilprivatisiert das wahr zu sein Gefühl sonst Zeitgeist ok da wird jetzt massiv Kohle gescheffelt haben es entstehen ganz neue möglich,
für Unternehmen wirtschaftlich und technisch zu agieren sie haben ganz neu
Möglichkeiten erhalten dass ich auf diesen Märkten mal mehr mal weniger anständig zu verhalten er wurde neben von Regulierungsbehörden er beabsichtige Rose dieser Prozess hat sich ganz Europa abgespielt was ist weiß nicht nur in Deutschland,
erfasse Zuschnitt rund Österreich wo auch wenn der kleinere Summe natürlich erzielt worden sind aber ich kann mich eben noch erinnern also in Österreich war das was ganz ganz schlimmen.
Ein mega 0:30 Uhr.
Super mega Hyper man sollte auch nicht zu weit gehen also diese diese hohen
Aktionspreise die die Netzbetreiber damals in Deutschland insbesondere in Deutschland gezahlt haben,
die holen Sie jetzt was ich 17/18 Jahre später immer noch als Ausrede hervor ja deswegen müssen halt deutsche Kunden so viel bezahlen weil heute starte ein bisschen
übersiedeln ausgeschlossen ist sollte man sich nicht vergessen wer diesen ganzen Beträge getan hat also das war schon eine freiwillige Entscheidung dieser Unternehmen.
AaO zweitens ist das
dieses von uns natürlich schon längst amortisiert oder dass das Spiel absolut keine Rolle mehr was ihm auch sehr sehr wichtig war ist es hat er mehrere Markt Konsolidierungen in den letzten Jahren oder mittlerweile heute Jahrzehnten gegeben also ich
verdichtet mal drauf diese ganzen Unternehmen wie sie mal hießen Mannesmann und so weiter,
Faktor sind von damals in server4 mittlerweile Nummer 3,
Netzbetreiber übergeblieben übrig geblieben dass es irgendwie data Telekom das ist Vodafone und das mittlerweile Telefonica.
Muss ich noch eine sehr wichtige Rolle gespielt hat es dabei warum die deutschen Mobilfunkpreise immer noch so hoch sind wahr dass die Unternehmen die
Telekom Deutschland und auch damals war noch Telekom Deutschland und Vodafone die hatten noch aus den 90er oder sogar 7 Personen aus den 80ern wenn ich mich nicht irre,
Frequenzen zur Verfügung die im relativ niedrigen Frequenzbereich gefunkt haben also ich glaube das waren die 800 Meter Frequenzen.
Die Standard GSM Frequenz genau darüber so fängt er an also Telekom und Mannesmann Mobilfunk damals halt noch später
im Vodafone haben ja Wahnsinn quasi die ersten beiden diese GSM Lizenzen bekommen haben und das waren halt die klassischen 809
Frequenzen dann kam dies war das war das D-Netz und dann Candy E-Netze
bezieht derselbe Standard nur andere Frequenzen das waren Anhalt E-Plus und Viag Interkom die dann halt später fusioniert wurden und somit unter dem Label halt o2 heute und,
die waren halt besser für die Stadt eine höhere Frequenzen kleinere Zellen die zitterer darauf haben die sich halt auch konzentriert und Telekom Vodafone haben halt mit denen niedrige Frequenzen das Land besser abdecken können dass er bis heute.
Aber nicht nur das sondern ist es auch dramatisch günstiger mit diesen niedrigeren Frequenzen eine möglichst flächendeckende Versorgung kommen abzubilden das heißt man muss jetzt nicht
alter Frequenzen Breitensee schlichten einfach besser aus Form der Flächen das hat muss man muss deutlich weniger Masten aufstellen um auf der sächlich
wenn du davor geschrieben sind Versorgungs Auflagen für dich erfüllen zu können das heißt
da war auf einer strukturellen Ebene hatten diese zwei Unternehmen einen massiven Wettbewerbsvorteilen wenn er durch der Nachzügler der ist dann später diese 1200m glaube ich anders oder aufjedenfall diese höheren Frequenzen dann erwarben hat das was jetzt 7 Uhr heute.
Tu es oder 1800 das was im Radio 21 respektiere Telefonica die hat,
zudem müssen viel viel mehr investieren auch noch mal um so halbwegs diese diese Versorgung in der Fläche dann auch tatsächlich.
Wobei es war ja für eine Zeitlang auch so das mal nachdenken wie das war aber ich meine mich erinnern zu können dass,
die Edith Betreiber teilweise auf den Netzen der Telekom oder Vodafone quasi mit gesegelt sind für einen bestimmten Zeit.
Also da quasi so ein Roaming ein
nationales Roaming stattfand falls obwohl ich woanders war konnte ich auch über 800 Megahertz Frequenzen mich in mein Netz einbuchen auch wenn es sich physisch um das Netz der Telekom oder Vodafone.
Dieter mit der Verpflichtung also das ganz.
So heißt das.
Genau die sogenannte diensteanbieterverpflichtung die diese gab es beispielsweise eben auch bei den USA UMTS-Netz in 3G Netzen,
wie ist dann leider Gottes bei LTE weggefahren
H&M mit kommen wir dann eigentlich langsam schon zum Kern haben wir begonnen nämlich 5g laut dem aktuellen Vorschlag das ist angeblich der finalen Entwurf Vorschlag der Bundesnetzagentur für diese Aktion,
soll diese auch nicht enthalten sein.
Also wie schon bei LTE.
Da muss man vielleicht noch seine kleine Sternchen machen so eine Fußnote da gab es für Telefonica oder hat ihm für zwei so einer Seite diensteanbieterverpflichtung das hat die EU-Kommission
bereits oberhalb reinfahren bluetooth die hat drauf bestanden damit die Versicherung überhaupt zustande kommen kann,
Hasen zu erzogener netzzusammenlegung über die Telekom Deutschland und Vodafone da gibt es keine den.
Ist aber ein ganz ganz wichtiges Instrument das klingt auch so sperrig das hat die deutsche Sprache muss ein bisschen Ansicht Diensteanbieter Belichtung.
Das sind diese ganzen virtuellen Netzbetreiber also eins und eins und und und Mobilteil und wie sie alle heißen.
Aldi was man halt alles so über alle Karten bekommen kann.
Die haben wir die Möglichkeit,
zum regulierten Preisen oder hattest du bestimmten Bedingungen die ganz klar sind wo Inhalt wird dir auch diskriminierungsfrei und ca zu marktüblichen Preisen dann auf auf eine bestehende Infrastruktur von anderen Netzbetreibern zugegriffen werden kann,
das sind ganz ganz elementare sind wichtiges Instrument wenn es denn keine 45,
Sex oder was auch immer Netzbetreiber gibt es mit einer eigenen physischen Infrastruktur das dann auch tatsächlich Wettbewerb auf diesen letzten stattfinden kann,
wenn es leben die Möglichkeit für Drittanbieter also dieser Anbieter Verpflichtung,
nicht vorgesehen ist dann teilen sich heute faktordrei riesengroßen Netzbetreiber das Land unter sich auf.
A und kann dann Preise diktieren aber das ist ein klassischer Fall in der Sohle.
Also das ist jetzt auch der Grund warum man ebenso oft solche Tarife stößt wie
ja hier kannst du zwar günstig telefonieren PC Internet haben aber du darfst nicht Chris Highspeed in Anführungsstrichen nur in 3G Netzen und du wirst nicht in ein LTE Netz ein.
Exakt das ist also nur in den Ausnahmefällen also was mt betrifft aber exakt also dass es ihm noch der Grund dafür
eine ganz ganz wichtige und manchmal ein bisschen unterschätze Komponente von diesem Mechanismus ist das diese
AT&T diensteanbieterverpflichtung für 3G langsam ausläuft das ist eine Sache und zweitens die Netzbetreiber langsam beginnen ihre Dagi net-m abzubauen und auf LED umzustellen aus unterschiedlichen Gründen.
Das bedeutet aber natürlich auch für mittlere und gar nicht mal so lange sich das erstmal die drei gehen dazu immer schlechter werden,
das frühere Spielzeug kaputt 20/20 und ich mir dass irgendwo aufgeschrieben, 20/20 darf ich diese diensteanbieterverpflichtung für 3G Netz im.
Am Ende könnte es nur so raus kommen dass sich wirklich nur die,
richtige reichen Leute entlassen können von 5g ganze.
Also nicht die Leute die Kunden sondern die Unternehmen.
Na da kommt ja die Unternehmen auch immer gut also wenn dann tatsächlich ja jetzt weder die Regulierungsbehörden noch die Politik etwas unternimmt dann läuft diese Verbindung aus und dann war's das mit.
Da gibt's ja nur noch die drei.
Ganz genau.
Es sei denn natürlich ist findet sich in vier Akteur der an dieser kommenden Frequenzversteigerung teilnehmen möchte was steht es noch in den Sternen ich halte das für eher unwahrscheinlich also so wie die,
Bedingungen der Zeit ausformuliert.
Ihr gerade mal nachgeschaut also an der 3G Versteigerung 2000 haben schon auch insgesamt elf teilgenommen,
teilweise wahrscheinlich auch einfach nur mit dem Ziel den anderen da die Preise hoch zu treiben ne Ergebnis war der Sopro Anbieter 16 einhalb Milliarden,
insgesamt 50 Milliarden für den deutschen Staat von uns,
die wir jetzt ab telefonieren müssen wir müssen 50 Milliarden ab telefonieren haltet euch ran.
Wir müssen die Staatsschulden getilgt werden.
Telefonierst du so lange ja ich muss Staatsschulden tilgen.
Ja was haben wir nicht damals für stolze Preise bezahlt ne gewisser Hinsicht ist es ja im internationalen Vergleich immer noch recht.
Wie sieht's denn jetzt konkret aus also es wurden dann Regeln formuliert für diese Auktion.
Sprechen jetzt von 5.
Von 5 kg von der Bundesnetzagentur die haben die sich selber ausgedacht oder gab es da auch eine politische Vorgabe oder hat man einfach nur copy pace das übernommen was bei LTE auch waren jetzt klebt an anderer Name.
Na das gibt's jetzt wahrscheinlich einen rechtlichen und politischen Rahmen der ganzen Sache das wird auf einer Seite doch europäisches Recht geregelt aber selbst wahrscheinlich auch insbesondere durch deutsches durch das Telekommunikationsgesetz,
was gibt einen groben Rahmen vor die sich die Regulierungsbehörden zu halten haben und die haben dann anhand dieser,
dieser Regeln oder so sagen sie zumindest die Regeln für diese Auktion
dann bestimmt da gibt es auch einigen Streit darüber ob die Einschätzung der Bundesnetzagentur so stimmt also beispielsweise eben diese Streitfrage ob es denn jetzt,
in anderen Auktionen teilnehmenden Unternehmen vorgeschrieben werden kann einen diensteanbieterverpflichtung dann in Kauf nehmen zu müssen oder eben nicht.
Die Pille ard.de aber Bundesnetzagentur hat das eben so ausgelegt mögen wir nicht also was die sagen ist ja so wir würden schon gern das Erfüllen was unter anderem im Koalitionsvertrag
C&A schwarz schwarz-roten Regierung steht nämlich neue Lizenzen nur gegen eine flächendicht Versorgung dass die sogar tatsächlich wirklich so drin so ganz klipp und klar
ja wir müssen 5g in Deutschland möglich schnell ausrollen wir müssen oder sollten zum Leitmarkt für 5g werden.
Und vor allem damit es auch wirklich nutzbar ist da muss es euch mal Flächen deckend möglichst rasch verfügbar sein werden wir ja einen diesen britischen Absichtserklärungen
haben die Regulierer einen Riegel vorgeschoben und sagen ja und sind halt die Hände gebunden weil ja die Gesetze so und so aussehen da können wir leider kurz nichts machen.
Welche Gesetze europäischen Gesetze in Deutsch.
Aber das ließe sich ja in vielen Ebenen durch Deutschland Gesetzesänderungen.
Das heißt die Politiker haben einfachen Wunsch und formuliert aber ihre von Ihnen selbst beschlossenen Gesetze widersprechen diesen Wünschen und deswegen konnte sie nicht Agentur da nichts machen.
Bleibt es an dieser Stelle machen in nicht uninteressant ein bisschen auszuholen,
geht dann nämlich schon brauchen diese grundsätzliche Frage wie verwalten wir starten wie schauen wir dass die Wirtschaft sich einerseits entfalten kann wenn man denn darauf besteht aber immer gleichzeitig nicht auf,
zu Lasten der Gesamtbevölkerung irgendwie agiert und da gibt's einen Prozess von ganz langen 20-30 Jahre zu beobachten.
Wo ihm sehr viel liberalisiert wurde sehr viel privat privatisiert wurde und so grundsätzlicher Mechanismen,
im Besonderen Kontinentaleuropa auf einen neuen Stand gebracht wurden nur ganz kurzer Exkurs,
von Westen an sich so zwei dominante Modelle entwickelt wie man tatsächlich jetzt eben starten und Wirtschaften organisiert und verwaltet das klassische.
Ganz unabhängig von Netzwerke.
Das ist vollkommen vollkommen unabhängig davon das reicht bis zurück ins 17 18 Jahrhundert also dass man wirklich einen großen historischen Bogen ich habe mich aber kurz.
So ganz ganz ganz grob in Kontinentaleuropa hat man so dieses klassische Modell der
der unabhängigen Bürokratie also du hast halt ein Ministerium und da hast du dann Beamter sitzen
und mit dem möglichst unabhängig bleiben er hat mir dann pragmatisiert das heißt da die waren die waren
unabhängige mehr oder weniger großem ist auf dem Papier hat aber ganz ganz wichtigen Effekt einfach weil dann nicht nach Gutdünken daher schon sagen kann okay das machen wir es mal so das machen wir mal so
am Samstag war zum gewissen Schutz gehabt um für Stabilität zu sorgen um für Vorhersehbarkeit zu sorgen sogenannte Rechtssicherheit zu schaffen das hat sich dann noch diesen monarchischen,
zu tun heraus in die Demokratie weiterentwickelt aber wie wir uns alle
aber ich hoffe jedenfalls bin noch immer noch ein bisschen, bis ich jetzt kommt Zeitgeister der 80er und 90er Jahre da wurde halt eine regelrechte Hetzjagd auf auf böse böse Falle ob aquatisiert,
Beamte losgetreten was ist überhaupt gar nicht möglich und verdienen viel zu fiesen nicht kündbar Besuch das böseste auf der Welt die machen alles kaputt,
also dieses eine kontinentaleuropäische Modell,
Hallo amerikanischen Bereich da sitzt man traditionell auf Regulierungsbehörden das sind von Meilen und auch nominell unabhängige Behörden.
Hat in erster Linie mit Experten besetzt werden mit sogenannten unabhängigen Experten die agieren sind dann schon der Exekutive unterstellt,
agieren am Montag an die Spitze je nach politischer Großwetterlage dann ausgetauscht werden,
wann sicher haben die die Funktion möglichst unabhängig möglichst unbeeinflussbar.
Und möglichst auf einer Experten Ebene genau diese Prozesse dann anzustoßen Regulierungsverfügung and auf den Tisch zu legen.
Und daneben.
Motorrad wirklich ganz konkret dafür zu sagen okay wir haben es ein bestimmtes technisches oder wirtschaftliches Problem es kommt dann etliche neue Technologie auf den Markt wie sehen die Rahmenbedingungen aus damit das auch wirklich tatsächlich gut über die Bühne laufen kann,
genau dieses anglo-amerikanische Modell der Regulierungsbehörden das ist umso im Zuge der 80er 90er Jahre,
auch in Kontinentaleuropa und insbesondere Telekommunikationsmarkt aber nicht nur dann übernommen worden.
Ich will doch gar nicht mal so groß die Beamten da sind wir noch mal verteidigen auch wenn es eigentlich immer für mich da doch dass das sympathische Ringmodell ist aber solche Regulierungsbehörden die haben,
ganz also da gibt's genauso wie Beamten Wirtschaft sozusagen einige Problemfelder hat,
ist doch eben genauso bei der Regulierungsbehörden warum geht's da gibt's so ein Rezept Gültigkeit.
Ziemlich also Einfluss zu nehmen auf,
die Besetzung dieser Behörden muss ich noch die Frage stellen wer sind den Experten aber wer sind denn diese unabhängig sperrten die angeblich ganz genau wissen wie der Hase läuft
die Kommunen in aller Regel aus der Wirtschaft
das wird dann zu ganz klassischen Problemen regulatory capture also wo Regulierungsbehörden von Industrie freundlichen
Visionen und fahr noch Menschen dann eingenommen werden aber das gibt diese sogenannten revolving door Phänomen woran Leute
in Wirtschaft arbeiten dann für 2-3 Jahre eher in Regulierungsbehörden landen dann wieder zurück in die Wirtschaft gehen und so dieses Rad von immer weiter drehen.
Über das jetzt auch in USA gerade gesehen haben mit der FCC und dem Ajit Pai der ist auch wieder versucht Ines neutralitäts Regio Regelungen außer Obama era zurückzudrehen.
Ja so diesen bereits abgeschafft ganz genau.
Haben aber wirklich so so festgestellt hat na oder Reaktion rausgestellt hat.
Sehr häufig und das ist eben auch jetzt bei dieser aktuellen 5g Entscheidung der Bundesnetzagentur zu beobachten das läuft,
extrem oft auf einer,
10 lustery und wirtschaftsfreundliche Position heraus jetzt ist eben das passiert das eben Deutschland oder ganz Europa genau diese Entscheidungen die eigentlich zutiefst politisch sind an,
angeblich um politische mit Experten besetzte Cremen ausgelagert hat den gibt es halt schon in groben Rahmen vor die treffen dann diese Entscheidungen angeblich unabhängigen Guthaben.
Jetzt haben wir eben dieses Phänomen zu beobachten dass genau diese Politiker die eigentlich dafür verantwortlich sind politische Entscheidungen und politische Rahmenbedingungen vorzugeben,
komplett Impotenz Inder in der Öffentlichkeit herum tuen irgendwelche komischen brandbriefe verschicken weil sich die Regulierungsbehörden.
Nichts,
haben Ihre Wünsche halten diese gern durchsetzen würden diese beispielsweise im Koalitionsvertrag gib unklar festgeschrieben haben,
also diese Entpolitisierung von zutiefst politischen
Fragestellungen und und Weichenstellungen die wirklich die in dem Fall die digitale Zukunft bedeuten da sich die Politik selbst entmachtet und ist jetzt plötzlich überrascht,
das Ihre Wünsche aus dem Koalitionsvertrag einfach nicht so ungefähr.
Heute Bundesnetzagentur muss ich doch quasi auch an Gesetzen ausrichten die ja vorher vom Bundestag beschlossen wurden also wo fehlt jetzt da genau der Einfluss.
Na was bist du hast also ein ein ganz großer Zankapfel ist ebendieser diensteanbieterverpflichtung da
schützt sich meines Wissens oder immer die die Bundesnetzagentur auf eine Studie eines sehr großen deutschen Telekommunikationsunternehmen wäre das jetzt ist lasse ich erstmal offen
aber da gibt's da wussten die das Gegenteil behaupten die sagen bis dato Telekommunikationsgesetz lässt sehr wohl diese Möglichkeit offen eine diensteanbieterverpflichtung reinzuschreiben genauso gut
sanovia wir knüpfen die Nutzungsrechte an diesen Film an diesen Mann Frequenzbändern an,
sehr sehr hohe Versorgungs auflagenbeschluss als Nebenfach nicht beispielsweise sondern in dem Fall wirklich 100% der Fläche oder oder 98% der Fläche und nicht 98% aller Haushalte.
Dass du mich ja auch so ein so ein Knackpunkt der aktuellen Diskussion es wird immer von 98% gesprochen das klingt ja auch wieder viel,
auch wenn 2% in Deutschland trotzdem noch eine ganze Menge ist sowohl Personen als auch Fläche,
aber dadurch dass man das sagt der Haushalte konzentriert sich das halt im Wesentlichen dann doch wieder auf den oberen Bereich Unterhalt auf dem Land nichts weil der wohnt ja dann kaum jemand zahlt man
2 Prozent der Bevölkerung verteilt auf die dünn besiedelten Gebiete Deutschlands weiß nicht wie viel Saarländer da jetzt zusammen kommen oder Fußballfelder ist die gängige Größe
na bist auf jeden Fall genug um weiterhin weiße Flecken auf der Landkarte.
Na und vor allem noch verdammt viele Menschen nicht zu versagen also wenn man alt genau die celltherm muss ein bisschen durch rechnet kommt man auf so ungefähr 1,7 1,8 Millionen Menschen
in Deutschland die man tatsächlich nicht da ist bei einer verpflichtenden 98 prozentigen Versorgung der Haushalte ist es immer noch in der,
Harzer Millionenstadt die unterm Strich dann nicht.
Ja und das sind ja auch.
Band Not.
Davon aus dass man bei Mobilfunk immer am selben Ort ist meine dafür braucht man kein Mobilfunk sein wenn man halt durch die Gegend fährt und Reis will man ja auch da Netz haben wo man nicht wohnt.
Die Funklöcher die werden definitiv nicht.
Genau das Herz in der ganzen Geschichte.
Na gut aber was hält denn jetzt sagen also wessen ist es jetzt nun struktureller Fehler wenn man sich mit diesem Modell der Bundesnetzagentur generell falsch aufgestellt hat oder ist es halt einfach nur dass die die die die Rechtslage so unklar.
Also die Rechtslage könnte es jetzt nicht so dass Politiker vollkommen machtlos werden wenn dem wirklich so viel dran liegen würde dann steht es Ihnen frei ausgesetzt Ordnung,
Oradea Bundesnetzagentur der Zusagen Jena-Winzerla ich habe dass die korrekten Paragraph mir rausgesucht hat Paragraph 150 unter Paragraph 60 des Telekommunikationsgesetzes,
erlaubt auf einer rechtlichen Ebenen die Einführung einer diensteanbieterverpflichtung,
wenn das nicht ausreicht kann man zum gleichen gesetzlichen Instruments greifen die dazu geführt hat das dazu geführt hat.
Im Zuge dieser Uhren teste tanzen virtuelle Netzbetreiber in die Netze lassen zu dürfen das hat früher noch ein bisschen anders geheißen,
noch ein ganz furchtbarer bürokratischer Name willkommen in Deutschland,
das war die Vorläuferin und oder zumindest Teile davon des TKG die Telekommunikations Kunden Schutzverordnung S7 nicht so dass der Politik komplett die Hände gebunden werden wenn in wirklich die digitale Spaltung so sehr am Herzen liegt,
ja und ich spreche jetzt in erster Linie natürlich von den Regierungsparteien und insbesondere von andreas Scheuer dem bundesverkehrsamt Infrastrukturminister dann ist es unmöglich,
einfach ein Gesetz zu erlassen und die Bundesnetzagentur auf einer gesetzlichen Ebene load.to zu zwingen tatsächlich auch,
politisch gewünschte Ergebnisse Herbert aber stattdessen stellt man sich gut vor der Presse
jammerst darüber wie die böse böse böse Netze Bundesnetzagentur und sich der ihr eigenes Süppchen kocht verschickt eben brandbriefe sowie die Unionsfraktion das getan hat die man dann halt so unter der Hand der Presse weitergibt ja schaut mal
so angepisst auf die Regulierer weil die machen nichts aber das was.
Auf der Grundlage ihrer eigenen Gesetze die sich bereit waren entsprechend scharf zu formulieren.
Ja dann gute Nacht was jetzt vor 30 Jahren aber welchen Scheidung hingefallen sind das kann man jetzt
diesen Leuten ist auch nicht persönliche und wie uns ans Bein binden aber trotzdem also es ist manchmal wirklich lächerlich machen kräftig an den Kopf und denkt sich was geht da vor.
Jetzt ist halt die Debatte,
dritte so ein bisschen im Kreis naja also die Telekommunikationsunternehmen Sahaja 5g das wäre alles ganz super und so das brauchen wir im Prinzip auch machen und wir bauen euch auch das tollste besten Hits ever und die Sonne geht auf
aber ist ja unheimlich teuer da können wir ja erstmal gar nicht soviel für bezahlen weil wir müssen ja auch noch investieren und wenn das jetzt zu teuer wird dann fehlt es natürlich das Geld für das Investment.
Borna das ist ja so so die eine Spielart die man diesen ganzen Spiel drin hat und natürlich ist dann jede Verpflichtung auf den Vollausbau macht ja dann noch viel teurer und ihr wollt doch auch dass wir schnell vorankommen,
Susanne Wunsch mit muss jetzt aber ganz schnell gehen so ja aber wenn es schnell gehen soll,
komme jetzt hier nicht irgendwie jeden Wald verletzen Katze irgendwie auch vor paar Tagen diese Äußerung von dem o2 geschäftsführer ja meinst du nachher hier Mobilfunk im Wald, denn dahin.
Braucht doch keiner wir soll denn das bezahlen,
was was denkst du darüber und vor allem was hat sich jetzt im Rahmen dieser Debatte den jetzt schon getan und verändert,
das ist überhaupt schon zu dieser Verzögerung kam.
Den ersten Entwurf dieser Vergaberegeln für diese Auktion den hat die Biene zu ende
immer wenn ich mit ihre vorgelegt daraufhin kam schon zu dieser Schlammschlacht die sich in den letzten Wochen Monaten in Deutschland abgespielt hat und jetzt letzte Woche hat sie so den angeblich finalen Entwurf,
am vorgelegt in dieser Debatte spielen dann mehrere Mechanismen eine ganz ganz zentrale Rolle.
Reguliere haben auch tatsächlich ein bisschen ihren finalen Entwurf angepasste aufgrund des wirklich Versicherung öffentlichen und politischen Drucks an,
aber zufriedengestellt hat das absolut überhaupt niemanden also sie hat,
beispielsweise nur sonst ein verhandlungs gebohrt dann reingeschrieben wo sie
Netzbetreiber mit einer eigenen Infrastruktur sozusagen mehr oder weniger sanfte Tod zwingend zumindest in Verhandlungen einzutreten mit einem virtuellen Anbieter der Interesse daran hat eine bestehende Infrastruktur zu nutzen
die Regulierer wollen dann in diesem Zusammenhang in seiner Schiedsrichter Rolle auftreten aber das ist
dass es keine keine Verpflichtung dazu das ist kein rechtlich abgesicherter Zugang zu diesen netten.
David Überbiss passieren dann was es geht ihm auch einige einige Mechanismen die es möglich machen den netzausbau.de schneller zu gestalten,
insgesamt in Sommer deutlich deutlich billiger haben und es gibt auch im Möglichkeiten dazu,
für dich mehr Wettbewerb als bisher inseala Menden und wirklich ziemlich desaströsen deutschen Telekommunikationsmarkt zu sorgen keinen einzigen.
Oder keinen einzigen Hebel der da bin jetzt aber zur Verfügung stehen würde.
Je nachdem wie man das Errechnen auslegt hat sie doch noch tatsächlich treffen also data diensteanbieterverpflichtung die haben wir schon besprochen nationales Roaming das Weben auch sondern Mechanismus mit dem sehr viel,
und nach Aufwand und Zeit gespart werden kann aber das bedeutet das Artefakt oder gleiche Mechanismus wie gesagt Rom dem Ausland ist Sprüche du hast einen bestimmten Netzanbieter der hat in einem bestimmten Gebiet nicht ausgebaut,
suppdiwupp kannst du heute das Netz eines bestimmten konkreten Nutzen aber das ist natürlich jetzt für den anderen Netzbetreiber nicht kostenlos das müssten wir sprechen zur marktübliche oder zumindest regulierte Preise sein also jetzt nicht so dass du dass sie verlieren würden.
Aber ging jeden einzelnen diese Punkte hat insbesondere die Telekommunikationsbranche sofalvi diese drei Platzhirschen dir zum deutschen Markt unterwegs sind,
massiv geschossen,
über Nacht einfach nicht sauer dass es da Konkurrenz gibt's die wollen auch nicht das virtuelle Anbieter gibt die wollen nicht dass ein IV oder möglicherweise V Anbieter noch zusätzlich als ich in den deutschen Markt oder irgendwie rein run Primel Trumpf
möglicherweise eine bessere Preisgestaltung und noch das großzügige red Datenvolumen noch zur Verfügung stellt,
die schon schon drauf dass wirklich jedes einzelne Instrument das irgendwie auf einer technischen als auch auf einer wirtschaftlichen Ebene möglich ist um die Versorgung besser zu machen und den Wettbewerb zu stärken
da um die Preise sinken zu lassen also da wären sie sich mit Händen und Füßen dagegen und bislang muss man sagen leider erfolgte.
Das ist ja alles höchst bedauerlich finde ich so weil wenn man mal drüber nachdenkt.
Wie ist vielleicht eigentlich sein müsste man es gibt.
So viele naheliegende Dinge erstmal worüber reden wir mit wem bei Mobilfunk da drüber das Hals,
ein natürlich Begrenzer Kommunikationsraum also das was man over-the-air an Frequenzen eben konkret benutzen kann jetzt unter verschiedenen Anbietern aufgeteilt werden soll,
und diese Aufteilung nimmt man quasi vor schon im allerersten Schritt so euer Netz darf die Frequenzen benutzen,
feuernetz darf die anderen Frequenzen benutzen und das war's du bist ja und wieso ein bisschen absurd weil er nie alle Frequenzen immer benutzt werden gleichzeitig wäre ja eigentlich viel sinnvoller wenn alle alle Frequenzen benutzen können,
in gewisser Hinsicht zumindest in Teilen gerade wenn es darum geht so ein schlecht versorgten Bereich,
zu bedienen wo dann alle sagen naja also dein Hintertupfingen ist ja viel zu teuer lohnt sich ja nicht gibt ja kaum Kunden und das sagen dann quasi alle drei würden die sich aber einfach ihre Frequenzen zusammenschmeißen,
Einmaster hinbauen den sie alle gemeinsam benutzen wo alle drei Netzkennung quasi.
Parallel ausgestrahlt werden auf denselben Frequenzen und die teilen sich auch noch die Kosten für diesen Bereich der wär doch alles super ist das noch so dass genau das sogar verboten ist diese Kooperation Möglichkeit.
NAC operieren das hat doch die Bundesnetzagentur dann jetzt glücklicherweise zu Prinz halt reingeschrieben ob das dann wirklich umgesetzt werden wird das ist steht auf einem anderen Blatt aber
Dieter Entwurf sie tatsächlich jarmark Operationsmöglichkeiten lässt den Netzbetreibern großzügigerweise,
ja oder läuft es ihnen das hätte zu kopieren smedbo Mobilfunkmasten zu schweren oder hat bestimmte Grund hätte ich ihn versucht Tour sich zu teilen verspäte.
Vollständig ne.
Nananananana.
Nee weil da gab's ja also die können sich ja durchaus Dinge teilen es steht jedem Menschen frei sich eine Glasfaser bei der Deutsche Telekom.
Aber die dürfen sich eben nicht den Didier Sendeeinheit oder sowas Teilen ne.
Ja aber das wäre doch gar nicht mal so dass wir auch gar nicht mal so notwendige so beispielsweise in nationales Roaming dass das LED.
Genau das dididi Idee scheint ja charmant weil wenn du jetzt nationales Roaming.
Hättest dann könnte sich ja jetzt einen Mobilfunkanbieter durchaus bemüßigt fühlen und sagen ich baue jetzt hier in dieses Funkloch,
sein großen Körner Oderwitz Ding hießen die zwei Millionen Einwohner Stadt klein großen gerne da baue ich jetzt mal so eine so eine Mobilfunk.
Anschluss hinten nicht nur gibt er mir das kleine Bisschen was meine eigenen Kunden,
jeder einbringen würden was sich vielleicht nicht lohnt sondern auch das wenn andere da rein Robben müssen meine Konkurrenz muss mich dann auch dafür bezahlen und dann stelle ich einen Mitarbeiter ab der den ganzen Tag bei Telekom Handy der telefoniert,
und schon wird das Ding vom Funkloch zur Cash Cow und hättest quasi einen Anreiz jeden einzelnen Anbieter hier,
Infrastruktur unter Umständen auch dazu bauen wo sich vielleicht bei singulärer Betrachtung nicht lohnt das wär doch glaube ich die Idee dahinter oder.
Das ist eine der Ideen die dahinter steckt die andere Idee die natürlich dahintersteckt ist das ist ein Aufbau eines Mückennetze sind natürlich insgesamt sehr sehr teuer
was man eigentlich hat das habe noch gar nicht mal erwähnt das sind die Frequenzbereiche die dazu verfügt hat die jetzt Auktionen eingestellt werden die sind im sehr hohen Bereich ja die sind aber zwei Gigahertz und im 3,7 oder 3,8 Gigahertz Bereich
das sind eben auch nur Frequenzen die einen ist eine sehr kurze Distanz und eine sehr gute Reichweite überhaupt zu erfüllen,
was heißt Umwelt wirklich eine Flächen der Versorgung hinzubekommen müsste man verdammt viele Masken bauen und da steht ändert sich die Effizienz Frage ist es wirklich sinnvoll,
dreimal eine Parallele in Facebook Tour überall in Deutschland hinzu Baden anstatt eine einzige und wieder,
immer auf einer technischen oder von der ökonomischen Ebene gelöst wird aber wäre es nicht viel sinnvoller eine Infrastruktur eine Basis in foto zu herauszustellen und auf der dann auf einer Diensteanbieter Ebene Wettbewerb laufen soll.
Dann kurz auf die Andi die alternativ Vorstellung von einem National Roaming wäre ja das ein,
anbieter Sonne Alibifunktion bei sich im Garten stellt und sagt den Rest der Zeit roame ich eben in den in den anderen Netzen na also das.
Ja so ist das kann man definitiv schon von einzelnen so ist es nicht gehört dass man jetzt einfach nur Roaming einführt und unten herrscht eben sein Wilder Westen nur das sollte natürlich sehr stark reglementiert werden
da wir natürlich auch auf einer kartellrechtlichen Ebene wenn er auch noch problematische geschäftsschädigende teurer als diskriminierungs Praxis möglich auch das lässt sich erlösen.
Zu den trink kleineren Zellengrößen würde ich noch kurz was sagen wollen es gibt das schon,
also das gab's schon für 3G sogenannte Femtozellen hast du in Deutschland eigentlich nicht gesehen wüsste ich nicht dass es jemals jemand gemacht hätte aber das,
konntest du hast jetzt Frankreich z.b. konntest du das bekommen das war Altenteil was im Prinzip an deinen Heimrouter mit dran kam.
Und dann über mobil also über die existierende lendlein dann einen 3G Netz.
Und ich glaube die haben das Ding auch für vier gehen noch gehabt da bin ich mir aber im Moment nicht hundertprozentig sicher.
Bei dir aufgebaut hat also 3G und 4G kannst das Backbone davon kannst du ja auf IP.
Bilden und dann wird also einer ein funksendemast in deiner Wohnung gestellt.
Oder Firma Tiergeschäft.
Genau für Geschäftskunden war das jetzt eh aber du konntest das auch als Privatperson bekommen als Unternehmen ist das natürlich insbesondere interessant weil du unter Umständen,
große Gebäude HS wo im Kern des Gebäudes kein Empfang herrscht oder große Glasgebäude hast die irgendwie mit metallbedampfte Scheiben sind und du hast quasi letztendlichen schönen großen Faraday cage ne mit den,
neueren Mobilfunknetzen wird das umso mehr notwendig sein solche kleinen und kleinsten Zellen,
zu errichten was wiederum zu einem Vorteil derer führt die ohnehin schon Geräte in den,
in den Wohnzimmern und Unternehmen der Menschen stehen haben also ich könnte mir sehr gut vorstellen dass es eine valide Strategie wäre z.b. als Deutsche Telekom dann Zusage na ja hier kommt der neue Speedport.
Damit hast du auch guten Handyempfang zu Hause und das Ding ist dann letztendlich eine Mobilfunkstation von T-Mobile.
Die Menschen in der in deiner Umgebung.
5g bietet die also diese die die technische Standards dafür gibt's zumindest alles gibt eine.
Technischen aber billig ist das jetzt wieder auch nicht dass ich hab das immer noch effizienter ja einfach ganz normal über IP also WLAN genau diese versorgen herzustellen dann möglicherweise mit zur Auswahl.
Bei 4G wiederum.
Telefonie über überall pidana durchzuführen da können ja moderne Handy Geräte drauf Umschalten dass es definitiv.
Stimmt das so ist das andere was ist in Frankreich auch gab mir die haben mir dann alles haben wir in Deutschland auch diskutiert du kriegst ein WLAN-Router,
und der kriegt ein Teil deiner Bandbreite steht der eben als öffentlicher Hotspot zur Verfügung und ruckzuck hatten sie so einen Hotspot System zum zum Teilen für die Leute also es gibt es gibt technische Lösungen,
und irgendwie regulation die.
Irgendwie an der Technischen Realität zum bisschen vorbeigeht und dummerweise am Ende irgendwie gegen die Interessen.
Eigentlich Allah steht oder.
Also die einzigen auch wenn sie in der Öffentlichkeit anders tun die einzigen die bis jetzt Stand der Dinge zufrieden sein können sind tatsächlich die drei Platzierten Hirschen in Deutschland das ist die großen Telekommunikation.
Also ich habe ja ich habe jetzt ein Bild deutsche Staatsbürgerschaft rum ja kürzlich und erlangt herum.
Erlangt so Leerung wäre jetzt also wir wohnen jetzt keine großartigen Steine in Weg gelegt.
Deutschkurs ablegen.
Ja Ausbildungsende na und so alles ganz unproblematisch wollte das nur sagen mir steht jetzt der Weg zur Bewerbung als Bundeskanzlerin im Prinzip frei.
Gehen wir mal davon aus das wäre dann jetzt auch schon soweit ja dann würde ich halt hier den Linus würde ich zu meinem digital Ministerinnen,
na der hat dann sozusagen das übergreifende resource also ähnlich ausgestattet wie das Finanzministerium darf also überall rein regieren jetzt machen wir hier so ein Beratungsgespräch ne
Herodes sie haben doch da ein bisschen Einblick wir wollen das jetzt mal ganz anders machen wie bauen wir denn die Zukunft ja wenn dann 6g kommt,
wie wie machen wir das dann alles viel besser.
Schick mir mal wieder auf diesen Telekommunikationsmarkt er sich so dermaßen schnell bewegt der so dermaßen viel Geld anzieht dermaßen wichtig ist für die Zukunft und irgendwie,
haben wir ein Oligopol System geschaffen was wir in anderen kritischen Netz Bereichen ja schon längst überwunden haben ne Gasanbieter,
irgendwie komischerweise kann ich jederzeit meinen Gasanbieter wechseln.
Ohne das Dach später hier Bautrupp ankommt und neu Gas Rohre verlegt werden,
genau dasselbe da bin ich jedes Mal wieder die Stromkabel aus der Wand gestimmt weil ich jetzt meinen Stromanbieter gewechselt habe und der Strom auch ganz anders erzeugt wird als vorher.
Hast du etwa den Stromanbieter gewechselt die reißen die Straße auf bist du wahnsinnig.
Wie ein Wunder ja also mein Mann fasst sich an Kopf wie wie wie das überhaupt möglich ist ja und das mit so sperrigen Gütern wie Gas z.b. also bitte übertragen so echt einfacher als Gas Übertrag
wir hätten es denn jetzt gern
die Baume denn das um sollte nicht einfach die Bundesrepublik Deutschland oder überhaupt in Europa jeder Staat selber diese Basis Infrastruktur aufbauen und für ein Glasfasernetz oder nimm eine Basis Funkversorgung mit
den Frequenzen die man dann halt nicht weg optioniert sein die man dann einfach hat und dann können sich alle darauf einmieten sowas bauen.
Also den letzten Jahren hatte ich schon gezeigt dass dieser.
Freimarkt Ansatz durchaus seine Probleme haben das sagt die sowohl im Mobilfunkbereich als auch im Festnetz Bereich.
Hat bestimmte Vorteile so ist das wieder auch nicht dass ich vielleicht auch nicht,
darauf drängen alles wieder zu verstaatlichen und wieder Monopolisten einzuführen das hat schon gewisse Gründe gehabt.
Einfacher durchspielen wo es sinnvoll wäre.
Aber in der Tat zeigt sich ja dass es Grenzen gibt wenn es darum geht eine,
Grund Infrastruktur für Grundbedürfnisse von Menschen zu schaffen und mittlerweile ist im Internet gehört sollte eigentlich ja zur Grundversorgung gehören genauso wie es bei Strom Gas Wasser und so weiter.
Oderstraße Lieblingsthema der deutschen der Fall ist,
also stellt sich wirklich immer mehr die Frage ob man auf der einen Seite sowohl volkswirtschaftlich enorm viel Geld sparen würden wenn man nicht einfach die gleiche Infrastruktur,
laut unserem Schlagwort Infrastruktur Wettbewerb,
mehrfachrahmen entweder die Hausdächer oder in den Boden verbuddelt sondern tatsächlich dafür sorgt eine möglichst gute möglich zukunftsfeste möglichst langfristig tragfähige Infrastruktur auf die Beine zu stellen,
kann und sollte eigentlich auch der Staat eine sehr wichtige wenn ich den scheiden der Rolle dabei spielen und dann wischen Vorwehen auf dieser infosoc Tour.
Tatsächlich Marktmechanismen atomizers commento lassen das Wehrmacht im Open Access Prinzip
funktioniert wie du schon erwähnt hast aber Strom und Gas ja relativ gut ist jetzt auch nicht perfekt aber langfristig
würden wir uns nach soviel Kaffee ersparen dann ist es ihm auch nicht so auf die Politik.
Bled ignorant wäre sie sieht schon wenn es ein signifikanter Anteil der Bevölkerung überhaupt gekämpft hat oder sehr schlecht damit Smith,
und Internet übers Festnetz versorgt wird irgendwann mal muss man auf diesem politischen Druck reagieren und dann kommen dann halt aber Instrumente zum Einsatz die mal mehr mal weniger fragwürdig sind,
som tam beispielsweise das hat er auch den letzten Jahren für hitzige Debatten gesorgt und wir noch die nächsten Jahre für Debatten sorgen dass es ihm dieses Breitband wird das Bundesförderprogramm für den Breitbandausbau,
aber werden mehr weniger direkt oder indirekt Telekommunikationsunternehmen mit Milliardenbeträge subventioniert
eine Debatte obwohl sie mir tun die Hacken Nackenhaare aufstellen das steht im nächsten übernächsten Jahr ins Haus nehme ich dir
Mama Universaldienstverordnung modern.
Muss erst zu einem späteren Koalitionsvertrag mal sehen wie diese Debatte ausgehen wird aber wurden ein gesetzliches Recht auf einen schnellen Internetzugang danach betätigt gesetzlich festgeschrieben werden soll
undressed Mannschaft dann jetzt über die Jahre in einer eh schon relativ komplexen komplizierten Situation einen komplexitäts leer,
übernächsten und das Ganze
Regelwerk wird noch kompliziert und noch komplizierter um in wieso zwei oder hat den Zielkonflikt irgendwie unter einen einen Hut zu bekommen nämlich einerseits ok wir
halten Nachricht vor am Markt getriebenen Ausbau und und und eine Verfügung stellen der Infrastruktur fest.
Gleichzeitig wollen wir aber auch dass Menschen nicht digital abgehängt werden aber sind nämlich schon ein wirklich entscheidendes politisches Thema und um diese zwei.
Nicht nur Menschen sondern auch Unternehmen.
Ja okay stimmt in Deutschland ganz ganz wichtig aber das ist schon richtig und,
wird immer komplizierter immer und ausziehbarer die Mechanismen um genau diese Sachen dann zu finanzieren oder quersubventionieren werden immer undurchschaubarer das öffnet undicht Tür und Tor für.
Seltsames Marktverhalten von Akteuren weil die natürlich nur noch je nachdem wie groß dieses Unternehmen ist
ganze Abteilungen Rechtsanwalt Rechtsanwältin gefühlt Abteilungen dazu verwenden kann Schlupflöcher zu finden in welche bestimmten Ausschreibungskriterien dich so zurechtzulegen das sollten möglichst viel davon profitieren aber da einfacher Bürger
der Schottland auf die Finger.
Ja dann fordere ich doch jetzt einfach die Einführung des digital Marxismus also dann müssen es einfach mal die Produktionsmittel,
die Hand der Maas nicht mal das jetzt ganz ernst also wäre es nicht sinnvoll hier mal eine konkrete Forderung aufzustellen die zumindest erstmal.
Saucenbasis macht sag mal mal man konzentriert sich auf,
die Versorgung des ländlichen Raums normal so steht es natürlich auch so ihre Probleme aber das man einfach sag,
okay wir definieren jetzt mal unterversorgte Bereiche.
Wenn es den Telekommunikationsunternehmen nicht innerhalb von drei Jahren gelingt hier eine hundertprozentige Mobilfunk und Gigabit Versorgung über dentlein herzustellen,
dann fällt der Zugriff automatisch an den Staat zurück,
da werden dann vielleicht auch Glasfasern verstaatlicht und die Frequenzen für den Mobilfunk fallen einfach wieder zurück in den Topf ja sorry habe dir nicht hinbekommen ist jetzt nicht mehr hours,
und dann übernimmt der Staat diesen,
Ausbau bzw Infrastruktur und die Wegerechte die schon da sind mal ganz krass gedacht so und dann übernimmt man baut auch aus diese Infrastruktur investiert also diese ganze Kohle einfach in den in den Aufbau von,
Tunnel Gewerken Glasfasern Verteilerzentrum in Zittau und dann schafft man quasi zugriffspunkte in diesen Ort.
Wo sich dann diese Unternehmen dann auch gerne drauf einmieten dürfen um diese,
Versorgung dann auch letztlich auf den letzten Metern zu bieten zum eigentlichen Zugang zum Internet anzubieten aber dann eben nicht mit zwei Jahresverträgen und sondern man kann das täglich wechseln,
also so so eine Bundes Internet Dose setzen.
Ich sehe da das noch problematischer auch wenn es jetzt mal auf dem ersten
klingt das wird aber aus meiner Sicht das Problem noch dramatisch verschlechtern das würde dann erst recht dazu führen dass auch lukrative Gebiete marktwirtschaftlich ausgebaut werden
unterversorgte Gebiete dass die nicht wirtschaftlich rentabel sind für sich Unternehmen dann einfach an den Staat zu sagen! Der muss das immer.
Wenn ich darauf beschränken.
Genau also wahrscheinlich wäre sinnvoller das ist ja auch unter dem Schlagwort das doctorella Separierung,
vorzugehen das in dem Fall wer das hat die Telekom Deutschland dass dieser Infrastrukturbereich selbst wieder.
Komplett verstaatlicht würde das sind ja ungefähr so 30% + - der dem Staat gehört,
ja wäre dann verpflichteter täglich eine deutschlandweite Basisinfrastruktur aufzubauen und auf die können sich dann übers Open Access Prinzip und andere Netzbetreiber drauf schalten.
Aber das Simsen rosinenpicken durch Anreize noch mal zu fördern dass ich ihm sehr sehr gefährlich aber das würde dann erst recht auf Lasten der Allgemeinheit stehen oder würden dann hat die Gewinne erst recht privatisiert,
die Verluste die wirtschaftlich unseren Tagen Gebiete das wär dann halt abends eine staatliche Aufgabe,
ist natürlich auch aber trotzdem geht's ihm darum SimSim Basisniveau herzustellen und zwar wirklich für alle,
Bürger und Bürgerinnen sonst haben wir halt wirklich eine digitale Spaltung oder wollte er starrt ständig nur in diesem komischen Bereichen mit dem Besen herum wischt und und 1:30 Uhr hinter dem Unternehmen die hat fette Gewinne machen deswegen.
Was wäre wenn man das einfach parallel jetzt aufzieht sowie es irgendwie Privatfernsehen und öffentlichen Rundfunk gibt
Bob man einfach jetzt ungeachtet der sonstigen Systematik einfach diese Infrastruktur aus und überall da wo es entsprechende Verteiler Punkte gibt
Tanja von Unternehmen im Auftrage des Staates durchgeführt werden können also betrieben werden können
da bitte man daneben offenen Zugang und schafft quasi so ein öffentlich-rechtliches Konkurrenzen.
Wenn du beim ja damit.
Gut Herr Neumann dann schreiben wir das doch bitte ins Gesetz der.
Ich vermute tatsächlich dass du da dann wie alle Gesetze die Unternehmen dich passen dass wir dann versuchen dagegen zu klagen und in dem Fall fürchte ich dass sie argumentieren würden dass sie in der
defacto eine Entwertung ihrer bisher geleisteten Zahlungen Lizenzgebühren stattfindet.
Das muss man klipp und klar sagen dass es definitiv illegal also das müsste auf einer gesamteuropäischen Ebenen wirklich komplett auf ganz Europa umgemünzt gelöst werden das einfach so kann man nicht machen aber das ist definitiv
muss ein Signal was mitschicken kann okay in diese Richtung soll es heute in Vogtareuth.
Ja und das stellst du jetzt nicht die nächste Frage.
Muss das Ganze nicht ohnehin jetzt auf europäischer Ebene eskaliert werden es gibt ja auch durch Ausländer die solchen Gedanken schon sehr viel offener gegenübersteht was ist teilweise auch schon so ähnlich machen Räumen skandinavisch.
Erbitte CT Möglichkeiten
den Mörder hat natürlich sehr sehr schwer ist das kannst du über Rahmenbedingungen selbst oder regulatorischen Rahmenbedingungen selbst zu leiten es ist möglich aber wenn man halt schon eine bestimmte historisch gewachsene magst du hat
aber bestimmte Entscheidungswege die sie hat sich halt so eingespielt haben ist es enorm schwer das Opfer auf der Basis genau diese Situation noch mal grundsätzlich zu ändern damit mal grundsätzlich ja,
eine bestimmte Sicht auf auf wirtschaftliche Prozesse hat soziale Gerechtigkeit und solche Sachen.
Pullover wenn man die Einführung einer einer öffentlich-rechtlichen Grundversorgung.
Rechtlich absichert auf Euro Ebene dementsprechend ist auch den Staaten erlaubt die Gelder entsprechend zu verteilen ja oder was weiß ich auch so einer Auktion,
genau diese Mittel z.b. auch dafür zu verwenden.
Das ist auch vorgesehen.
Was kommt in einem Zukunfts Topf oder wie auch immer der heißt.
Ein Zukunft stop.
Der soll dann unter anderem auch für den Ausbau der digitalen fußdoktor.
Okay na gut dann können wir ja dann auch gleich den nächsten Schritt.
Wir geben das Geld aus wir verwalten.
Mit eben dieser Sinneswandel ist derzeit einfach noch nicht da und ich hab so den Eindruck da muss mehr in diese Richtung auch argumentiert und debattiert.
Stimmt schon wobei Fairness halber muss man dazu sagen dass die Linken in diese Richtung argumentieren die Grünen haben so eine,
vizion aber sind definitiv auch so diese digitale Spaltung Unterzahl Gerechtigkeitssinn sie sehr im Vordergrund und mit Abstrichen wird es sogar für die FDP also sogar die fordert eine strukturelle Separierung der Telekom,
am unterfüttern ganz konkret als Beispiel ich habe das von ihrem Wahlprogramm der letzten Wahl,
nehme ich aber so bist du mit der Deutschen Bahn passiert oder bzw wir hätten das gern auf dieser gleichen Ebene.
Badebomben Vorbild also.
Was war heute die Meldung jeder jeder 5 DICE kann als funktionsfähig eingestuft werden.
Parking thinking Saturnus Schienennetz.
Das während Dienst was ändern die Diensteanbieter die auf dieser Infrastruktur dann tatsächlich mal mehr mal weniger gut funktionierende Züge laufen lassen würden aber die die Schienen selbst die sollte runter im tatsächlich der Stadt sind und so.
Sich so also meiner Meinung nach ist eigentlich für die Einführung des digital Marxismus ist alles die Zeichen sind gesetzt müssen noch die Ministerien.
Diesen sind gelegt die Weichen sind gestellt.
Ich weiß nicht gestellt und geschieht wird gelegt in der Neumann dann sitzt du das mal bitte um Kabinettsbeschluss.
Und achten Sie bitte darauf dann haben wenn ich sie schon dran habe,
am Tannenweg ganz ganz wichtige Sachen über diese ganzen V Einführung auch noch auf dem Spiel steht ist nehme ich eine so oft vielen Eberle nicht diese Standard auf eine technische Verbesserungen so dass schafft das Frequenz
Beckum besser aus wird besser auf auf Spiegelungen und und man kann meme oder mitfahren das auch zu wlan bekannt multipel ins multiplied
eine Funktion die potenziell sehr gut aber auch sehr sehr schlecht sein kann,
sind die sogenannten netrix license oder metrickz leises na das ist eine offene technischen Ebene recht faszinierende Technik damit lassen sich nämlich auf einer physikalischen Ebene,
mehrere wenn ich beliebig viele virtuelle Netze betreiben das heißt du kannst dann Netz auf einer bestimmten Infrastruktur in unterschiedliche kleine Segmente aufteilen und da kannst du dann,
wenn es halt zu machte Telekom in Forst industrien,
über einen letzten Planung Beispiel auch übers vor oft übers Farbe ändern auf deine Firma zugreifen und das andere ist für Videostreaming gedacht das dritte Rad fahren jetzt nur autonome Autos blabla.
Aber so toll das klingt ein so viel Potenzial das hat das hat ein riesen Potenzial nehme ich für die Telekommunikationsindustrie.
Weil die sagen das sind Dienste Klassen und innerhalb von Dienste Klassen diskriminieren wir nicht aber zwischen Dienstag lassen oder.
Dank dem Wasser das ist sehr auslegungsbedürftig aber im Prinzip ist es ein riesiges potenzielles Einfallstor um tatsächlich die Netzneutralität
also da hätte man auf einem technischen Ebene sehr leichte Möglichkeit sogenannte Spezialdienste anzubieten oder einfach nett sein,
die hat einfach zu Dampf geringe Latenz haben sehr schnelle Bandbreiten zulassen immer verfügbar sind und so weiter und
wann hat man heute ein schlechtes schlechtes Netz
okay also um um die unterschiedlichen Dienstag lassen da da abbilden zu können und zwar regelkonform das ist jetzt zwar nicht einfach möglich aber da gibt's definitiv noch noch viel.
Potential auf Missbrauch daneben wir haben in der Schule Feuer wenst Thomas Lohninger einen fantastischen Artikel bei uns also bei netzpolitik.org und nichts veröffentlicht,
warum liegen ganz im Detail drauf eingeht nicht nur wird diese Evaluierung Cardada,
Anna Überbiss Netzneutralität Regelungen in den nächsten Jahren über die Bühne gehen wird sondern auch welches Missbrauchspotential ebendiese network slicing Technik.
Im Telekommunikationsindustrie Unternehmen bietet also Herr Namen bitte achten sie drauf Netzneutralität das ganze.
Wir müssen Chancen und Risiken abwägen.
Chancen und Risiken abwägen.
Licht und Schatten neue Technologie.
Ja wobei ich fände es sehr schön wenn wir ein bisschen mehr Licht in der neuen Technologie hätten.
Ja ich möchte Gasphase.
Banner für andere Themen machen.
Ja können wir machen was haben wir denn noch.
Ich würde ganz kurz noch das Feedback zur letzten Sendungen insbesondere zu beim Funk.
Funkzellenabfrage transparent System sammeln und zwar.
Deutsch.
Wollen wir von mehreren Leuten auf hingsen ins unter anderem Katrin immerhin erhält man zwei Erinnerungs SMS kurz vor ablaufende 90 Tage und dann noch einmal eine SMS wenn man nicht mehr dabei ist und die SMS erhält
enthält auch den Link zum verlängern und neu anmelden das heißt man muss sich keinen
kann Kalender Wiedervorlage oder sonstiges einrichten die ich in der letzten Sendung gescherzt habe.
Manuel kommentiert aber auch noch wenn man sich dort registriert gibt es muss man die Vorwahl auswählen,
kannst halt die klassischen deutschen Vorwahlen für Mobilfunknetze auswählen nicht jedoch die klassischen österreichischen australischen US-amerikanischen und sonstigen,
das heißt aber natürlich nicht dass du nicht trotzdem.
Ziel einer Funkzellenabfrage würdest und die Argumentation dass man das jetzt noch nicht anbietet diesen Dienst für ausländische Teilnehmerinnen,
ist dass es aus Kostengründen nicht passiert also ist auch versch also Teil verständlich.
Kosten Fall ja auch an für diese SMS zur Registrierung und Verlängerung und so eine SMS ins Ausland wer eben auf Dauer relativ teuer ja es ist könnt ja hier ist eine Situation sein.
Dass Menschen sich jetzt eben alle aus Australien da irgendwie registrieren für dieses Funkzellen
Abfrage transparent System und die bekommen dann eben alle 90 Tage diese SMS und so weiter und das wäre würde ihm auch zu den laufenden Kosten dieses System ist beitragen befriedigend finde ich aber auch diese Situation eben.
Nicht also der erste Schritt den haben wir auch schon der letzten Sendung gewürdigt jetzt müssen wir wir schauen dass wir das.
So ausgestaltet bekommen dass es auch wirklich Fahrt aufnimmt soviel noch mal zu dem Funkzellenabfrage transparent System.
Dann haben wir auch darüber gesprochen dass er jetzt die technische Richtlinie Router.
Endlich vom BSI veröffentlicht wurde,
ich hier darf ich regelmäßig darüber berichtet dass diese technische Richtlinie angestrengt wurde in Reaktion auf diesen Telekom Router Ausfall ja das war ja ein.
Gewissermaßen ein Schockmoment in Deutschland 900.000 Router fallen aus.
Relativ zügig gab es da zwei Anhörungen im Deutschen Bundestag die glaube ich
mindestens eine oder vielleicht sogar beide war nicht öffentlich einmal im Verkehrsausschuss und einmal im Innenausschuss oder so ich glaube dass ich da bei beiden war ich kann mich schon gar nicht mehr daran erinnern,
und das
Innenministerium bzw Wirtschaftsministerium und Innenministerium fühlten sich bemüßigt Wirtschaftsministerium ging ran und machte den Aufschlag zu was kann man denn da tun
Innenministerium in Form von BSI übernahm dann hat gesagt das schreiben wir jetzt eine technische Richtlinie.
Um endlich für Sicherheit in diesem Router Bereich zu sorgen denn das kann ja nicht sein dass die ausfallen
das geht so nicht und wir wurden als CCC da auch eingeladen konnten konnte ich nach Bonn fahren hatte auch erwähnt ich war nicht der einzige da hingefahren ist Frank ist auch mal hingefahren und an den späteren Sitzungen ist,
Mirko jedes Mal vertreten gewesen Mirko Vogt.
Und wir uns ja so angeschaut und wir haben da die Vorschläge des CCC vertreten und die primär waren.
Alle Forderungen die wir immer wieder vortragen werden gerne erstens,
ein Mindesthaltbarkeitsdatum dieser Begriff Mindesthaltbarkeitsdatum.
Ist so eine griffig daher gesagt es geht darum dass ich die Anbieter verpflichten müssen für eine gewisse Zeit.
Bestenfalls natürlich einen langen Zeitraum und einen von einer Richtlinie oder Gesetz vorgegebenen Zeitraum den Kram den sie in Umlauf bringen mit Update zu versorgen.
Wäre ja ganz schön kaufst dir einen Router steht dran oder am besten wäre es natürlich gesetzlich ist.
Der Hersteller verpflichtet dich mindestens fünf Jahre dir gleich mal eine realistische Lebenszeit dieses Gerätes sind das Gerät mit Updates zu versorgen Sicherheitsupdates zu versorgen.
Man könnte das auch Garantie nennen man könnte das Herstellung wie erwähnt also.
Garantierte Lebensdauer.
Garantierte Lebensdauer einmal konnte das alles mögliche nennen Mindesthaltbarkeitsdatum weil irgendwie auch der einleuchtende Begriff weil steht auf der Verpackung drauf ne kaufst dir den you Plastik,
Joghurt unten Plastik Router,
der eine hält bis nächste Woche und der andere ist,
Bio-Joghurt der hält noch eine Woche länger.
Beim Fleisch steht immer bitte verbrauchen.
Daytona.
Danach nur noch im Kühlschrank.
Datenvolumen bitte verbrauchen.
Die das war die erste Forderung wir eingebracht haben jetzt kommt die zweite Forderung wenn dieser Mindestzeitraum vorbei ist.
Dann kann das ja nicht sein dass dieses Gerät mit einer Sicherheitslücke in Zukunft dann eben entweder zu einem Risiko für.
Im schlimmsten Fall die,
nationale Sicherheit wird weil es in den Cyberwar zieht falls von irgendjemanden gehackt wurde oder ausfällt oder sonstiges,
oder alternativ zu frühzeitigen Elektroschock obwohl das ja Elektroschrott obwohl das ja noch tut ja der ist ja noch gut.
Also an wir gesagt wir hätten gerne dadrin nach Ablauf dieser Zeit spätestens,
aber eigentlich immer wäre es schön wenn eine alternative Software eingespielt werden könnte da wir ja tatsächlich sehr gute funktionierende,
situ alternativ surface haben insbesondere Oppenweher t.
Eine Linux-Distribution die für viele,
klassische Heimrouter verfügbar ist und die genutzt werden kann um auch relativ betagte Geräte auf zumindest softwareseitig einen guten Stand der Technik zu.
Alternativ Varianten davon wären du hast jetzt eben wieder eine Software du entscheidest dich als Hersteller,
deine Router Modelle nun nach der gesetzlichen Mindesthaltbarkeit von 5 Jahren nicht mehr zu supporten dann könntest du ja z.b. auch den Quellcode öffentlich machen na also es gibt ja verschiedene Spielarten
sie alle leben aber davon dass eine alternativ Software Installation auf diesem Gerät notwendig.
Also erlaubt sein muss und nicht technisch verhindert werden da was ist aus diesen Forderungen geworden.
Mindesthaltbarkeitsdatum diese Angaben müssen nicht wie gefordert in standardisierter Weise schon auf der Verpackung stehen,
es gibt auch keinen von der Technischen Richtlinie vorgegebenes Datum sondern oder Zeitraum sondern die in,
das BSI sagt in der Technischen Richtlinie wird kein Zeitraum festgeschrieben und er muss auch nicht drauf gedrückt werden sondern er muss für den das einen frei wählbaren Zeitraum als Hersteller.
Und diesen kannst du vor dem Kauf transparent auf deiner Webseite benennen,
super cool für deine Situationen im Leine Einkaufszentrum Zion ja du als Kunde muss also jetzt selber noch mal in die Recherche gehen und irgendwo gucken ob er irgendeiner Webseite,
steht wie lange das Gerät noch Software Update bekommt oder sodass.
Um nachzuschlagen Wasser steht es nur für drei Monate.
Ja also total also die diese ihr wohl wirklich relativ eindeutig dass diese.
Anforderung der technischen Richtlinien wirklich vollständig und sie vorbeigeht ne.
Das ist echt geil also früher haben.
Könnte man auch mal stell dir vor du stehst im Biomarkt ja guck stehst vor so im Joghurt der steht kein Mindesthaltbarkeitsdatum kannst ja mit angucken völlig in Ordnung.
Bis zu 1m Media Markt drin wo du eh komischerweise kein Empfang hast,
so prinzipiell ist ja jetzt da der Aufklärung Genüge getan die Information ist ja irgendwo verfügbar.
Kleingedruckte hat noch nicht ausreichend zu Kunden Verwirrung beigetragen jetzt sind Erding wir diese Informationen irgendwo im Internet wo keiner mehr weiß wo überhaupt noch irgendwas.
Selah Sue,
es ist nun wirklich auch für Laien nachvollziehbar dass dass das einfach verpufft ja auch unsere Forderung zudem einspielen alternativer Software wurde,
nicht entsprochen das wurde als jetzt also diese Forderungen gibt's nicht es ist nicht vorgeschrieben und des BSI sagt dazu,
die Möglichkeit zur Installation alternativer Software bietet kein Push ein Sicherheitsgewinn also.
Wir haben als TTC dazu einer Pressemitteilung veröffentlicht in der wir eben sagen hier das ist doch nun wirklich sehr enttäuschend dieses Ergebnis.
Und das Biest diese Kritik hat das BSI wo so getroffen dass sie.
Auch tatsächlich eine Stellungnahme zur Kritik an der Technischen Richtlinie für Breitband-Router veröffentlicht haben in der sie allen Ernstes eben sagen
die technische Richtlinie ist ein erster Schritt zu mehr als die Sicherheit für die Anwender und du fragst Dich wo passiert das denn,
ja wo passiert das denn behaupten dass eine valide Grundlage für die Vergleichbarkeit und Nachweisbarkeit der Sicherheitsleistung verschiedener Geräte wir haben sind aber mal angetreten,
nicht um irgendwie.
An irgendwelchen Internetseiten die irgendjemand unterhält theoretisch die Möglichkeit zu schaffen dass diejenigen Anbieter die sich entscheiden an dieser technischen Richtlinien mitzumachen das kommt ja noch dazu sehr vollkommen freiwillig,
die können ersetzt irgendwo im Internet schreiben ja übrigens so und so lange machen wir das ja hier grünes Häkchen 5 Jahre Support oder so.
Aber steht eben nicht da drauf und die schämen sich noch nicht einmal zu sagen.
In der Technischen Richtlinie einen bestimmten Zeitraum festzuschreiben indem die Hersteller Sicherheitsupdates bereitstellen müssen erzeugt nicht automatisch mehr Sicherheit,
echame die sich nicht so eine Behauptung aufzustellen völliger völlig klar ne das ein wenn du eine wenn du ein Sicherheitsproblem hast.
Dann erzeugt das Update mehr Sicherheit.
Kannst du das nochmals wiederholen ich bin heute nicht ganz mitbekommen.
Schon geil sieht ja wirklich so es ist auch für die Verbraucherinnen und Verbraucher sinnvoller wenn der Hersteller diesen Zeitraum dynamisch kommunizieren kann Statin frühzeitig und zulassen der Kunden festzuschreiben,
dich frühzeitig sondern dann erst gleich nach dem Kauf oder so und dann.
Ja nee wir hatten jetzt letzte Woche am ein halbes Jahr garantiert aber es einfach ging nicht also es nur noch an.
Das habe ich also völlig völliger Unsinn dann sagen sie finde ich ja so geil die machen die schreiben eine richtige und sagen.
Die Information sollte
auf der Webseite des Herstellers zu Verfügung stehen kann aber auch an anderen Stellen kommuniziert bei dir klappt der Ersteller kann auch einfach einen sicheren Router bauen der Hersteller kann auch länger die Updates bereit schon der Hersteller kann auch die Installation alternativer Software ermöglichen der Hersteller kann sogar was weiß ich
10 Jahre lang Updates bereitstellt aber wofür schreiben wir eine Richtlinie wenn wir irgendwie sagen ey yo geil alles kann nichts muss.
Du brauchst doch keine richtige zu schreiben.
Aber diese Formulierung ist ja noch Krankheit darf ich dir das noch mal vorlesen aus Sicht des BSI ist es auch für die Verbraucherinnen und Verbraucher sinnvoller wenn der Hersteller diesen Zeitraum dynamisch kommunizieren kann
Papa Stadt in frühzeitig und jetzt der Knaller zu Lasten der Kunden festzuschreiben wo ist wo ist denn das bitte eine Last.
Wir gehen davon aus dass jetzt vielleicht der Hersteller sagt ich mache nur drei Jahre und dann ist das zu Lasten der Kunden.
Oder das ist natürlich,
kann ein ein zusätzlicher Aufwand entstehen würde wenn man es an wann ruht auf den Markt bringt da in diese drei Jahre drauf und dann müsste man halbgare Weise dynamisch dafür sorgen dass ihnen das so wie das Joghurt regelmäßig ausgetauscht wird
müssen noch diese Aufkleber dann in den Shop ja noch entsprechend dynamisch angepasst werden das kostet Geld also das ist meine Interpretation dieses,
der seltsamen ist.
Ist doch relativ einfach solange das da da da drauf steht das Gerät kriegt was weiß ich einen Zeitraum,
gemäß Richtlinie ab Kaufdatum Updates und solange das Ding noch irgendwo sich im Vertrieb befindet muss der Hersteller für Update Sorgen fertig.
Also naja wollten sie nicht.
Was heißt denn auch die Formulierung bisher wurden weder Transparenz noch die Reaktion auf Sicherheitslücken an zentraler Stelle von den Herstellern gefordert.
Ja das ist das tolle dass es so das ist wirklich das ist schief Mann der Technischen Richtlinie Router es wurde jetzt etwas gefordert und niemanden muss es muss dementsprechend.
Und das ist es also abgesehen davon dass wir das eh schon vor er gefordert hat und ist wirklich lächerlich wirklich nicht nachvollziehbar,
sagen sie in PI.
Leider ist der Einsatz von VPN Routern mit bekannten aber nicht geschlossen Sicherheitslücken immer noch verbreitet dies wurde jüngst durch eine Studie des American consumer Instituts belegt ja und ihr werdet nichts daran ändern,
mit eurer richte eine alternative Software ja sagen sie auch defacto Transe auch falsche zweite Typo in diesem Ding sagen sie,
sie würde es erlauben ja danke,
danke stimmt übrigens es ist tatsächlich so gewesen dass der insbesondere der Verband Deutscher Kabelnetzbetreiber das spezifisch verbieten wollte.
Alternative Software einzuspielen.
Und dette rühmt sich jetzt das BSI eben damit andere Späße sind sie haben.
In dieser Richtlinie quasi das wofür du etwas überhaupt ein Sicherheits Fall ist den du beheben musst dass ihr wie bei einem cvss von 6 angelegt dass das ist relativ hoch,
also cvss ist das Carmen Val nobility scoring system,
und das ist also soll quasi Vergleichbarkeit in der Bewertung von.
Von Sicherheitslücken ermöglichen,
und da gibst du also quasi an unter welchen Bedingungen kann diese Richtlinien der kann diese Schwachstelle ausgenutzt werden und welche negativen Folgen hat das und dann kommst du auf einen Wert.
Dieser ist mit 6 schon gleich mal relativ hoch.
Außerdem sehr schön ist im Text steht drin die Hersteller werden.
Ermutigt oder angehalten otps anzuwenden für den login.
Otps hier gemeint one-time passwords.
In irgendeiner Form so eine Art Zwei-Faktor-Authentifizierung oder so und sie erklären die Abkürzung aber mit One-Time-Pad.
Was etwas ganz anderes ist One-Time-Pad ist nämlich eine,
also quasi eine angegebene N11 fixer nur einmal verwendet habe vorher definierter Pfeiffer stream für Verschlüsselungen also muss jetzt nicht erklären ist wirklich was ganz anderes und wirft kein gutes Licht.
Das BSI das in hier dieser Fehler nicht aufgefallen ist.
Also abschließend hier hätte eine Chance gegeben wir haben jetzt eine freiwillige Richtlinie für die Hersteller die müssen der nicht entsprechen sie werden es natürlich tun aber insgesamt ist die,
leider eben sehr zahnlos und das Ziel tatsächlich Maßnahmen zu ergreifen die eine,
Sicherheit der Geräte erhöhen wurde hier.
Nachhaltig leider aus den Augen verloren denn vergessen wir nicht Sicherheit ist insbesondere.
Ein Prozess und nicht ein Zustand und,
das ist hier wie so oft beim BSI aus den Augen verloren worden und diese Veranstaltungen zur,
Formulierung der Technischen Richtlinie waren eine sehr ernüchternde Situation in der eben,
am Ende technisch nicht besonders.
Mit Erfahrung gesegnete Lobbyisten bemüht waren die wirtschaftlichen Interessen der Unternehmen durchzusetzen und es gab relativ wenige.
Gruppierung die dort mit Sachverstand tatsächlich an der Idee gearbeitet haben die Sicherheit dieser Geräte zu erhöhen und die Sicherheit der Kundinnen und Kunden die diese Geräte kaufen.
Leider sehr enttäuschendes Ergebnis denn wir sind da ja mit anderen,
Hoffnungen reingegangen sind da ja es immer muss jedes Mal nach Bonn fahren.
Also das Wetter es ist einfach sehr sehr ernüchternd.
Was wir da erlebt haben und wir hätten uns dann natürlich mehr erhofft und allein die Stellungnahme des BSI jetzt da zeigt natürlich das.
Wenn sie schreiben selber noch besser als wir das das Ding wirklich zahnlos.
So bevor wir zu sein Kurzmeldungen kommen bis dann verabschieden wir dann Gast.
Der thomas hat leider nicht genug Zeit sich die vier Stunden Kurzmeldungen jetzt noch.
Wir machen das ganz schnell auf Arbeit jetzt haben wir schon 13 Uhr.
Bei uns immer das längste insofern hast du das sehr riecht.
Dass du lieber jetzt die Gelegenheit nutzt doch noch bisschen bei netzpolitik.org zu arbeiten.
Ja ich muss arbeiten bitte danke für die Einladung da hat es Spaß gemacht auch wenn es ein trockenes umfangreiches mega kompliziert ist Thema ist aber.
Digitale Zukunft Deutschlands diam.
Die gerade verkacken.
Spiel steht so was man möchte der Welt.
Deviled gut.
Ja dann wünsche ich euch viel Spaß noch bei den Kurzmeldungen wie ich sehe es stehen ja noch einige lustige Themen auf der Tagesordnung.
Wir sind da auf jeden Fall noch bemüht vielen Dank.
Mit Vorderschinken.
Tschüss ja dann machen wir doch weiter was war denn noch.
Wir begrüßen Thomas Halde Wangen als Nachfolger von Hans-Georg Maaßen.
Thomas raus an thomas rein.
Der war bis dahin der Stellvertreter von Hans-Georg Maaßen also der Vizepräsident und wurde jetzt befördert.
Ist also ich meine auch wieder sehr schöne wie lange Seehofer darum gefackelt hat sich zu überlegen dass er eine Nachfolge suchen muss.
Hat er dann am Ende doch auch alle Seehofer vorher mal ein bisschen länger um auf die offensichtliche ID zukommen ne klassischerweise wenn Nachfolger gesucht werden nimmst.
Aber mal den viel zunehmen ja.
Hat Seehofer hat irgendwer jemandem Seehofer jetzt gesteckt und über Thomas Heiterwang wächst auch sofort in seinen Abend und hat.
Direkt noch mal den Zugriff auf verschlüsselte Kommunikation gefordert davor gewarnt dass die.
Dass der Geheimdienst blind wurde wegen des going dark ja und.
Sem procedure as last year Miss Sophie.
Genau er ist so schnell als ich es schnell in seine Rolle hineingewachsen und.
Ja auf die Frage was denn jetzt anders machen oder repräsentieren würde als sein Vorgänger meinte,
ja er hat eine rote Brille und trägt keine Weste und dann wissen wir ja schon
auf was wollen sie einstellen können wenn mal gespannt ob er in irgendeiner Form in seiner öffentlichen Darstellung
besondere Bezug auf rechtsgerichtete Parteien da einen anderen Ton findet aber am Ende waren sie sich ja immer sehr einig,
der Herr Halde Wangen und der Herr Maaßen.
Bis jetzt ist noch jeder in sein Amt hineingewachsen ne.
Außer Donald Trump.
Außer Donald Trump und un.
Schauen wir mal was dabei rauskommt ist noch was rausgekommen.
Eine eine klassische Weisheit ist ja nur weil du paranoid bist heißt es nicht dass sie nicht trotzdem hinter dir her sind.
Klassisch.
Eine der eine der letzten hartnäckigen Verschwörungstheorien im Bereich Wikileaks als ich jetzt auch endlich doch als wahr erwiesen,
eigentlich redete also Julien erforschen,
beredet ich weiß nicht seit wie vielen Jahren davon dass es ein sogenanntes zielt indightment gegen ihn gebe übersetzt heißt das eine,
unter Verschluss befindliche Anklageschrift eine geheime Anklageschrift die im Prinzip vorbereitet bei den,
zuständige US-Behörden liegt aber noch nicht,
ich wurde einfach weil man.
Natürlich strategische Vorteile daraus zieht wenn das noch nicht der Fall ist wird also einerseits sieht er aus in seinem mit seinem Aufenthalt in der ecuadorianischen Botschaft Wien Bilder Verschwörungstheoretiker,
der sich gegen die Untersuchung in Schweden Wert mit dem
Moment nein das ist ein Vorwand um mich an die USA auszuliefern die USA könnte ich den Stuhlgang was verlassen schwer sind sie in der Anklage gegen sie können wir uns hier also, weder bestätigen noch,
noch leugnen aber im Prinzip gibt's hier nichts zweitens je nachdem was darin.
Eventuell in Anwältin natürlich auch die Möglichkeit sich darauf vorzubereiten oder entsprechende dagegen,
vor zu gehen oder zu handeln ja also es macht strategisch durchaus für die USA sind hier eine geheime Anklageschrift zu haben.
Und interessanterweise hat sich das jetzt mehr oder weniger ausversehen.
Bewahrheitet diese Verschwörungstheorie denn in einer Hand Notiz in einer Aktennotiz in einem anderen Fall.
Gibt es eine App für Notizen die darauf verweisen dass es das eben gibt.
Und.
Es wohl was durcheinander gebracht worden heißt es darf.
Also da gibt's doch immer drin also ein bestimmter Staatsanwalt.
Oder eine Staatsanwältin hat hier geschrieben
das muss hier versiegelt bleiben bis hier Assange haftet haben oder weniger genau
die Tatsache also mal schauen welche Verschwörungstheorien sich da sonst noch in Zukunft bewahrheiten werden aber das war eine die im Prinzip auch so lange und so oft wiederholt wurde manchmal
zweifelt man ja dann auch an dem News value von solchen Dingen als diese Meldung kam habe ich das war so eine wo ich direkt Nummer aus Datum geachtet habe dachte so hell wie das darüber reden wir doch schon seit Jahren.
Aber das ist jetzt tatsächlich die erste öffentliche Bestätigung dessen wovon im Prinzip im Umfeld von Wikileaks seid,
gehe die Rede ist also schon bevor er überhaupt sind überhaupt die die.
TV bis dahin immer angebliche Existenz diese Anklageschrift war überhaupt seinen Grund in diese ecuadorianische Botschaft einzuziehen vor vier Jahren oder fünf Jahren wie lange das inzwischen her.
Ja also es ist jetzt sowieso ziemlich offen wie es so mit Assange weitergeht weil sein einziger Schutz.
Engel Raphael Korea durfte ja nicht,
mehr antreten zur Wahl des Präsidenten
und dementsprechend ist er das auch nicht mehr und mittlerweile allerdings wird gegen ihn auch mittels gibt eine Anklage wegen Entführung und Bildung einer kriminellen Vereinigung
also da geht's auf jeden Fall
auch richtig zu Sache und ist bin ich mir gerade nicht so ganz sicher aber hat der sich nicht auch mittlerweile irgendwie irgendwo in Sicherheit gebracht also es ist.
Eine eine wilde Räuberpistole die sich da abspielt und es ist nicht davon auszugehen dass diese Schutz den Ecuador darüber MRA schanzes gehalten hat noch lange,
hält allerdings ist er ja glaube ich mittlerweile ecuadorianische Staatsbürger also von daher weiß ich nicht beschützt ihn das vielleicht noch in irgendeiner Form aber
würde mal sagen.
Am Ende wenn der Schaden für Ecuador größer ist als das was sie da mein für sich rausholen zu können.
Also Korea ist inzwischen glaube ich in Belgien.
Belgien a.
Und.
Dumont.
Die Situation zwischen der neuen Regierung und erforscht verschärft sich zusehends Ecuador gibt eben immer mehr Auflagen wie er sich bitte zu verhalten habe die.
Die Botschaft in der sich da aufhält ist auch wirklich sehr klein.
Und S7 offenbar zusehends das Interesse daran verloren dass er ihn außenpolitische Schwierigkeiten bereitet durch seine Tätigkeiten in das Internet ab und er hat jetzt auch irgendwie angegeben
vor dem Menschengerichtshof irgendwie gegen Ecuador Klagen zu wollen und der Situation dieser schwelende Reifenbrand da,
ist da auch irgendwie von Ungewissen.
All Korea ist nach Belgien,
ausgewandert weil seine Frau aus Belgien ist.
Koreaner in Nordkorea nicht hahaha.
Ja und wird jetzt mittlerweile mit internationalem Haftbefehl gesucht also so schnell kann sich.
Gut damit haben wir unsere Kurzmeldungen durch und wie sollte es anders sein das bringt uns dann zu den Terminen.
In Unna eröffnet die unhackbar.
Und zwar dieses Wochenende am 24.11 ab 15 Uhr in der morgenstraße 6 beginne Nudelsalat Kuchen oder Kohlenhydrate in der euch angenehmsten Form mit.
Und da ist ein Parkplatz in der Nähe und ihr kommt aber auch über epnv hin und Nuggets also jetzt einen schönen neun hackspace.
Ein weitere Gelegenheit auszugehen ist in Wien der findet der netzpolitischer Abend in Wien Stadt so schön wie das Internet ist es dort und,
auch wenn man kein über 30 trauen soll auch der 31 netzpolitischer Abend der hier stattfindet.
Ist sicherlich lohnenswert das ganze findet statt am 5. Dezember 2018 ab 19:30 Uhr im Metall abgeben in Wien.
Das wären die Termine jetzt gewesen ne Congress ist ausverkauft.
Brauche nicht mehr erwähnen.
Oma nicht mehr zu RWE.
Aber es gibt jetzt Camper Tickets noch zu kaufen.
Jetzt gibt's aber der geht Dicker sehr schön ich habe festgestellt dass sehr viele Leute jetzt Ihre oder mehrere Leute und auch noch ihre ihre Cookie values getwittert haben aus der EU gestern und.
Und jetzt werden wir diesen diesen Kongress veranstalten.
Jetzt gedacht zum 35 mal was für dich die ganze Menge Zeit.
Ja ist es ich habe nicht bei allen 35 Kongressen das wäre meine Frage gibt es überhaupt einen Menschen der bei allen 35 Kongressen war wahrscheinlich nicht.
Fürchten das Zeug selbst die langweiligsten Besucher.
Ich hätte auch eine Vermutung wer das sein könnte.
Andy müller-maguhn.
Ja okay ja stimmt der wird wahrscheinlich bei allen gewesen sein.
Vielleicht bin ich nicht aber den ersten aber auf jeden Fall.
Wig hätte ich ansonsten online Verdacht.
Auch Option es gibt schon noch ein paar harte.
Absolut absolut.
Ich will ich war beim ersten aber ich war nicht bei allen.
Wasser messen.
Aber nur so als Zaungast also ich war so am Nachmittag lang mal da,
so was ist denn das hier und so aber ich habe gesehen.
Märchenkoffer ich noch flüssig.
Wozu noch verfestigt ja.
Suppe hat sich schon entwickelt die Veranstaltung ist schon bemerkenswert so sagen dass
Grad ist das Experiment in Leipzig das wird noch sehr spannend werden in diesen Jahren und ja ist viel gesagt worden über diese diese Größe und die Dimension der Veranstaltung aber ich muss auch mal wieder,
im Kern immer noch dieselbe veranstaltet.
Ja ja ja natürlich aber es nicht mehr mein Kongress das ist eine
das ist tatsächlich sehr schön also bitte raus aus den verschiedensten Richtungen.
Sowas dann gesagt ne bei jeder bei jeder minimal Veränderungen ne.
Das ist nicht mehr mein Kongress es war nie deine Nummer 1.
Zeit ist genau das ist der Kongress was er ja irgendeiner Form im Wandel bleibt und neue Dinge entstehen und vor allem Dinge entwickelt werden.
Sei es in den SMD size auf den Bühnen und wenn nicht mehr dein Congress ist ist jetzt auch nicht schlimm ne also war ich immer,
der von allen irgendwie und wurde Kongresses das was alle die da hingehen daraus machen und das ist doch in der Regel etwas sehr schön ist und wenn du es also sitzen nicht so als.
Also ich sag mal.
Das ist nicht mehr mein Kongress ist eine Äußerung die ich insgesamt nicht ganz verstehe weil der Kongress immer das ist was du irgendwie draus machst und wenn du und auf der Veranstaltung wirklich nichts mehr findest was,
Bier jetzt zusagt im Sinne von programm auf der Bühne.
Gestaltungsmöglichkeiten in Workshops Diskussions Wirklichkeiten mit Gruppierungen die da sind dann ist das tatsächlich sehr sehr schade.
Jan vor allem sollte man dann einfach auch mal drüber nachdenken ob man nicht das was von dem man meint dass es fehlt selber mit ein,
also ich habe mal wieder gesehen dass viele Gestaltungsmöglichkeiten gibt es eigentlich auch jedes Wachstum immer wieder neue Möglichkeiten geschafft haben also auch jetzt in Leipzig.
Oder sauer weil letztes Mal in Leipzig sind diese Räume wieder mit Dingen gefüllt worden die so,
einfach vorher nicht gab so aber falls ich der Späti oder diese Rennbahn oder so Sachen die vorher so nicht denkbar waren und die einfach Kreativität.
Ermöglichen die sich ausleben kann vor halt nicht so da war.
Oder auch ihre Nummer um einen bei Spülmaschine Chaos West die da irgendwie ein riesen ist Emily hinziehen mit Bühne und eigenem Programm und so weiter Nase da da ist.
Davon lebt ja der Kongress dass man ihn sich so gestalten kann wie man selber eben ihn auch gerne hätte.
Nun denn wer von euch Ticket hat Gattern können und kommt wir freuen uns auf jeden Fall sehr darauf und wie immer sprechen uns an wenn ihr uns seht könnt gerne alle mal Hallo sagen
und Mama jetzt erstmal nicht beizutragen sende oder.
Wetter in natürlich in nächster Zeit noch so ein paar Ankündigungen machen was auf dem Congresse passiert.
Ja das machen wir wahrscheinlich eher erst im Dezember,
dann würde ich jetzt gerne noch ein bisschen Dank loswerden,
und zwar an Hans Helmut Philipp Christian Sören Benjamin Tobias Björn Peter Daniel Martin Michael und Toni.
Und ich weiß dass er jetzt zwei Personen fehlen deren E-Mail ich gerade nicht finden konnte bei denen schuldig mich jetzt schon dass ihr beim nächsten Mal.
Okay Sandra.